ladies and gentlemen i have sitting in
front of me the very
oh no he pressed the button and sitting
with the uh
top of the org chart for the tim cast
media organization he's changing
he's leaving his name is bucko
and uh he's the boss so he is yes he's
out he was hanging out for a little bit
yeah
we got to schedule it with him next time
we're live we have to get an appointment
hey yeah you know he's really hard to
get a hold of he sleeps all day he does
he's the epitome of capitalism i mean
he's the boss he does no work
his eyes are half closed he lazily sits
there and we break our backs every day
and then he's the one who gets the
rewards he hasn't got to pay any bills
he gets all his food and everything
taken care of
yeah even to clean up his body it's
lovable i hope you're all enjoying the
show
uh hey everybody how's it going welcome
to teamcast irl if you haven't already
um subscribe smash the like button and
we got a bunch of stories a lot having
to do with
antifa riots this autonomous zone in
minneapolis
the chavin trial and what's going on
with some of the jurors
apparently today in the good old pacific
northwest anti-foes out about trying to
smash
their way into banks there's like a
photo of a cop coming out he's got a gun
and so we're talking about a lot of this
stuff and we'll get into what's going on
we also have got uh
cuomo he's being referred uh his actions
to
the police the latest harassment claim
against them is fairly serious i suppose
and uh and we'll get in all this stuff
there's some other cool stuff aoc and
matt gates working together on marijuana
legalization
and then we've got some gun control laws
and we're talking about a lot of guns
but today we are hanging out with kim
iverson do you want to introduce
yourself
um well i'm kim iverson i'm a political
youtuber
right um for now while youtube keeps me
on
and um i'm i would say i'm a progressive
on the progressive left
but um libertarian but like the tulsi
kind of progresses right i was a big
tulsi supporter and more of a
progressive yeah more libertarian
progressive if there is a thing
it's it's politically homeless i guess
i don't yeah i don't know if i am though
i think there's enough of me
enough of you yeah so i don't feel like
i'm that homeless i just think that we
don't
i think we haven't um figured out our
address yet
i should put it that way the numbers
haven't been put on the house but
there's a house
well it's i think you know you're
critical of war and you criticize the
democrats and you've
criticized coveted lockdowns right that
i was the only progressive i think
actually who that's what kind of
differentiated me and then a lot of
people started calling me
far right or something well that
basically means yeah of course if you
don't agree with the orthodoxy in the
cathedral
maybe that's the easiest way to to put
it it doesn't matter what your political
alignment is are you with or against the
cathedral
you know they call this heretics yeah
you're a heretic or you're
sort of heretics i'm definitely
anti-establishment
yeah for sure anti-elitist yeah uh
yeah i don't know i mean um i guess it
depends on what you mean by that because
some elites are also anti-establishment
yeah you know i wouldn't right for sure
yeah right he's an outsider you know so
it's like
elon musk i would say he's
in that so i don't know if i'm
anti-elite i'm not anti-rich people
you know i'm not anti that but aren't
progressives you know eat the rich tax
the rich
i well i would like to right yeah so you
know more taxes i guess for the rich i
suppose but
yeah but so i would say
anti-establishment for sure
anti-war well anti-needless war
yeah not a dove yeah sometimes war is
necessary i suppose sounds like you're
just a reasonable person
that's what i would say that's why i
think that i'm not alone in my house
i think we're all in a similar house but
it is like a lonely party
and it's not because i think most people
probably agree with with a lot of things
we would all say
disagreeing a lot of things too but the
main agreement is that we can have the
conversation
but i think a lot of people are just
scared and would prefer to just say you
know tell me what to say i
don't want to get kicked out so they're
they're hanging out in the establishment
house
because they got they got all the big
beers and all the big tv shows and
there's a lot of people who will
they won't deliver at our house because
there's no address yet exactly right
it's true see it's really frustrating we
got ian chilling hey everybody what's up
crossland in the house going great man
yeah it's going pretty good
nice couple days we talked kim and i
talked last night about not tarot but
you know power cards like
tim's an ace of spades maybe we can get
into it later yeah you're a six of
spades
yeah what does that mean is an eight of
diamonds that's a really
that's like the best card ace of spades
you know that song by
motorhead yeah i think ace of spades i
mean we could get into it i'll let you
know everything you need to know about
being an ace of spades
my mom's an ace of spades princess diana
was an asus man
yes what was her birthday wait i don't
know but she was an ace of spades how
does that make you an ace of spades well
because
the way it works is so it's based on a
deck of cards but this is back before
playing cards were playing cards this is
actually the system that this was built
on
was um uh when playing cards are
actually
a sort of like a bible to a certain
group
of people and they think that it may be
stemmed from people
somewhere in the middle east a system so
you know you've got chinese astrology
right with what year you're born and
then you have western astrology with
like your pisces i'm in arie we're aries
right leo here so um this one
is some sort of middle eastern astrology
and they based it on a deck of cards and
basically each day
has a different card and of course
there's 52 cards and there's more than
52 days
so some cards get reused some cards
don't so
some cards i believe there's as many as
13 days associated with one single card
that have march 9th is ace of spades
march 9th is ace of spades so everybody
born on march 9th is an ace of spades
but then
i think then also i could tell you
everybody born uh
i believe april it would be april 11th i
think is also
maybe it's april 11th or maybe it's
april no april 7th
sorry everybody born april 7th is also
an ace of spades
um so it's like let's let's let's i want
to talk about this but we'll start with
the news stuff first
yeah let's get that out to the crazy
stuff and that's not what my show is
about i don't want anybody
i love it it's just a side hobby of what
i like
it's just something like that but i am
legit okay all right i believe it
foreign policy expert i mean more or
less right that's your that's your area
of focus
right mostly well until covent and then
i got into the virus stuff and i started
talking about that stuff a lot but yeah
foreign policy was probably my biggest
you know big fan of tulsi gabbard friend
of hers
um and um that sort of you know was
really in that
lane a lot criticizing foreign policy
traveled around
you know to kind of see some stuff for
myself we're all big fans of tulsi
yeah i love her yeah tulsi is great
she's really great you know
we'll see what she's gonna do well let's
let's let's get into the politics don't
forget we also got sour patch lists
yeah you're in the corner i am mashing
buttons and keeping it on the cat he's
running around
yeah it's it's really nerve-wracking
having boss like wander around
overwhelmed
i feel really nervous he took his keys
he's looking good yeah and we don't even
know what his card is
he was up here one time during the show
he started peeing in the corner it's
true did you imagine your boss in
i mean it's his house the cat is not
really our boss we're joking
like this is what i think of this show
that's right good work everyone
my friends uh before we get started how
about
i actually pull up this website that's
one site that's the
site you need to go to go to tim kelly
wait wait wait no oh no
it is the site you know what the site it
is why is it's giving me the business
okay there we go all right there we go
go to timcast.com become a member we got
a bunch of
exciting bonus episodes we talked uh
more extensively with scott pressler the
other night about how he's trying to go
after the america last politicians and
primary them
and so it was really interesting
conversation but look at this amazing
library of content
some of it's very offensive like when
jack murphy said progressives can't be
alpha and marxism is objectively
anti-masculine and he's holding a beer
as he says it
uh but then we have some fun stuff like
ben stewart we were talking about alien
civilizations and dmt
and we talked about that with clifton
duncan for some reason so become a
member because you can watch these fun
uh
bonus segments and exclusive members
only stuff and it helps us in the event
that you know we get banned because we
talk about things the establishment
probably doesn't like
and uh like share subscribe and if
you're listening on itunes or spotify
then leave us a good review because man
that really really does help give us all
of the stars
but let's let's talk about the uh the
first big story here
we have this from the post-millennial
anti-fuss storm into banks in portland
try to break inside federal courthouse
just another day in portland
the right capital of the united states
and there's this photo of like an armed
cop and there's a bunch of people in
front
let's just read they say dramatic scene
unfolded in portland this afternoon
as antifa and other left-wing activists
tried to break into the chase into a
chase bank
a loan security guard managed to hold
off the mob with his pistol
the post millennial editor at large andy
noe posted footage from a left-wing mob
and a bank security guard the source of
nose videos is an account titled 45th
parallel absurdist brigade
who documented the day's activities they
seem to be sympathetic to the protest's
cause seeing as they got nostalgic when
passing by the federal courthouse
where last summer antifa hosted nightly
sieges against authorities
the day's demonstrations was a gathering
meant to protest against something
called line three
which according to a piece last month
from the guardian is an upcoming
pipeline proposal to transfer nearly one
million barrels of tar sands a day from
alberta canada
to superior wisconsin a move that is
facing pushback
from activists over it being constructed
through native american lands
as well as concerns about the health of
the water supply as a result
the protesters went to chase bank
because they're reportedly one of the
funders of the line three pipeline
project
the demonstrators made their way inside
after a standoff
after tagging the chase in a nearby
apple store with graffiti the protest
made its way to wells fargo for an
encore performance
it all came back around to the hatfield
courthouse where dhs
and the antifa crowd are in a standoff
at the time of at the time of writing
federal officers are currently
responding to protect the courthouse as
the anti-crowd starts up their routine
property damage to the area
all right there was there were a lot of
stories we were like what should we open
with there's a lot going on you know
cuomo is you know facing some kind of
criminal charges
but this one really like wrapped up a
bunch of stories you got a pipeline from
canada
you got native american lands you've got
ante for riding you've got the
courthouse back in play and banks
it's like a fruit punch medley of all of
the things that they're uh
upset about and i gotta i gotta be
honest kind of just doesn't make sense
you know so we we've been kind of
following these stories about what's
been going on with antifa over the past
year or so
and i'm interested actually to get your
take kim considering you know you view
yourself as progressive
you focus heavily on foreign policy but
also lockdown stuff just like what you
think about what's been going on and how
you feel about these uh these
individuals
like what do i think about how antifa
and everything that's been going on with
that
like jazz chop areas and all these other
things going on
yeah i mean i personally the way i view
it in just kind of like an overview
kind of uh looking from the top down
sort of
you know if i were an alien coming to
earth it just looks like
everybody's becoming a little bit
radicalized in the united states and i
think it's a normal thing to become
radicalized so as somebody who studies a
lot of foreign policy
looking at groups like isis al qaeda
right terrorist organizations
how do people get recruited into those
organizations right
they get recruited in because their life
isn't
where they want their life to be they're
not getting the resources that they need
to live a good life they don't feel like
they can have a a a life with a good
faith you know make have a family and
have all the things an
opportunity they're lacking opportunity
so they join these extremist
organizations
and i think what we're seeing happen
here in the united states is that same
lack of opportunity
that is happening on both sides of the
aisle because it's just people
in general not getting that opportunity
are now looking for
a place to kind of get their anger out
and so we're seeing it manifest in a
variety of ways and i think that
some of the youth are really going after
like
the they're kind of going and creating
these uh zones like
the you know chaz chop or they're just i
think they're just holding
finding some ideology to hold on to to
be like
yeah this is well are they really mad
about any of this stuff like like
no no it's not that and that's what
that's kind of my point is my point is
they're not
mad about they're just exerting their
anger somewhere
anywhere and they just find a group that
they think kind of aligns with them on
something and they say okay this sounds
good and you're going to help me get my
opportunity back because we're going to
take the country back
and it's that same exact mentality what
are they what are these what are these
antifa people who are
protesting in in minneapolis right
setting up this new autonomous zone
i understand you could argue they're mad
about the george floyd thing
but when you see them actually go out
they went to a chase bank because it's
some way
related that one chase bank has
something to do with it i understand i
guess the brand is a symbol of what they
oppose
but i wonder it seems like they just
went out and said
we're gonna get violent you know we're
gonna we're gonna smash so they go to
the courthouse they go to different
banks they went to wells fargo i guess
because banks are bad
they go smash windows at starbucks i get
that
that they're angry but what are they
angry about like
you mentioned that people get
radicalized because they don't have the
resources they need
i mean these people i can certainly
understand the coveted lockdowns
but many of these people i mean
regardless you're still living in one of
the wealthiest countries in the world is
it a lack of perspective
like they've not seen how bad it really
is in other countries so they just
assume they have it bad and it's really
just
i just don't think we can live the
american dream anymore and that's what i
think the issue is well
i mean you've been able to live the
american dream and many of us have been
able to but not everybody can i mean a
lot of us are just riddled in student
debt i have 35
000 of student loans that i've been
paying on for 17 years
i still owe 32 thousand dollars very
similarly for many
years and i i definitely agree that's
like i'm for student loan forgiveness
for sure
but i think it should be based on the
principle of what you borrowed and you
pay back
sure i mean there's a lot of nuances to
it right but it's the overall you know
and there's many ways we can go about
doing things like student loan
forgiveness because
obviously we have to fix the system and
not just hey we're going to give
everybody a check that's you know
there's a lot but my point really is
that they're we're in a society right
now
that we were all told when we were
children that we could have
the two-car house fence minivan
stay-at-home spouse potentially to raise
the kids
go on a vacation once a year to grand
canyon or times square or disney world
and that we could go and then you have
your starter home and then you upgrade
your house and then you
you know all of these basic things that
are grandparents the greatest gender the
great generation what are they called
the greatest generation
yeah what they were able to have we were
all told we could have that
and then something went wrong and
suddenly especially after 2008
boomers lost and many of them lost their
retirement so a lot of them are now
stuck in apartments
and after losing their houses and then
the millennials and gen xers
and gen z are not able to then recreate
what the greatest generation was able to
create
and we were told all as little children
we were going to be able to do this so
that's the angst
so some of us are able to go and maybe
have money
make money uh you know do that but the
problem is is that it's not at the same
level or scale that was able to do that
before
i think the problem is college i think
college is the main problem
and looking at antifa you know i'll i'll
just give a shout out to this viral post
from reddit
it was this it was from r cringe so this
is like a prominent
subreddit it's like a very viral video
and it's this young woman who looks
you know uh she you know typical kind of
attractive she's doing the normal things
wearing makeup her hair is you know
looking good and then it's like first
year of college and her head's shaved
and it's like her hair is just like
straggly and pink and she's like
screaming and shrieking at the camera
like
whoa what happened to you
they go to college and they they enter
these weird environments
and it's like this person was angry and
they didn't even graduate
what happened where she's in high school
and she's like your typical high school
uh you know
girl and then she joined she goes to
college and in her first
year she becomes this so like i
definitely see what you're saying i
think we can ex we can expand upon
like angst and the denial of what we
were promised and things like that
but what's this thing like you go to
college one year and also they're
anti-fun
they're dressing like crazy people i
don't think that's most college
experience
i think that's very specific to like
certain universities that take on that
vibe like berkeley
is one or um you know i don't know maybe
yale
i guess i don't know i don't really pay
much attention to that but
you know when i went to college it was i
went to uc i went to seven different
schools to be honest with you and then i
finally ended up at uc davis was my
final school
and there you know everybody's nose to
the grindstone just working and
everybody's you know the
it's that's all they're doing they're
just studying so i do think that there
is some
of that radicalization that happens um
but i don't know if that's and i what
that where that becomes a real problem
is they dominate the conversation
right so what we're getting is this real
woke-ism style
you know that everybody's a racist bigot
now
yeah you're double white i'm double
white double white but you're more
double what than i am
that makes me more more yeah more white
right more white yeah i'm not allowed to
talk race topics i've found
the the people who like look the people
who are
who are starving these banks and
fighting at these federal courthouses
it's not the majority
of people it is those who are getting
radicalized right because there are
certainly a lot of people like look you
have student loan debt you're upset
about it you're not going around
smashing windows
i might start don't smash
[Laughter]
pay my loans off smash
apparently the stuff works you get
violent you freak people out and they
get on their knees and say please stop
please don't hurt me
i don't know if it does because i mean i
think when the other side you know when
there's um
depends on who does it right after
january 6 it seems like that's not
exactly what happened
oh yeah i think it's fair i think it's
fair to criticize
um to that extent that it was like the
capitol building during the joint
session of congress to count the
electoral votes
so that holds a lot of weight with why
it was particularly egregious
but unlike they've stormed you know the
far left has stormed local
state buildings like capitol buildings
local courthouses they've literally
stormed the congressional buildings and
more than one occasion
they were trying they're banging on the
door and smashing it during the
kavanaugh hearing so it's like
i think it's worse to go after the
average person take your angst out on
the right people
at least these antifa people i'll give
them credit they didn't go after the mom
and pop shops they went after the actual
institutions they're angry at
after mom
you know because before they were going
into my neighborhood i mean they came to
my house i mean they came
wow during the summer we had armed
invaders in our complex and we were all
told to go into lockdown
not covered lockdown but an actual
lockdown we had helicopters swarming
above
and we had armed the you want to say
what city you live in i live in l.a
yeah yeah wow so people went into your
complex or whatever yeah what happened
was
there's like a group of armed riders
looters or whatever and they had
looted a place a business and then they
got in their getaway car
and drove off and the cops were chasing
after them and they drove into my
complex of all places and they got out
of their car and they got into our
building
and they were hiding in our building
with guns it's a good thing you guys are
armed and you have excellent gun laws
funny thing so i'm from idaho and i've
always been even though i've always
identified as a liberal and more of a
democrat even though now not but
um i the one thing that i never really
agreed with others
on my side of the aisle were about guns
i'm a big pro second amendment person
i'm from idaho you know i don't know
maybe
i'm sure there's anti-second amendment
people in idaho so i shouldn't
generalize
um but after that i will say everybody
in in my
complex i live in a very liberal area of
la as well
and everybody was very always been
anti-gun and after that
at the dog park i'd go to the dog park
with my dog and i'd overhear the
conversations
and people would say you know i never
thought about owning a gun
there it is now i'm thinking about
buying a gun
yeah it really shakes you and i always
tell people
yeah i mean look at what's happened in
the cities i mean we were locking down
people were coming to our house we had
uh my neighborhood was totally destroyed
by the looters
and they were my uncle's businesses i
mean my aunt's business got totally
she had boarded up wow you know and to
and
immigrant and by the way refugee you
know immigrants
uh with businesses that have been able
to work hard and have the american dream
in a way and had to board up their
businesses and now
i don't know if there is there is a a
a cultural practice among my people when
these riots happen
they get on top of the roofs of their
stores and uh
it's it's a weird thing to bring up
because i know there's like you know
count dankula
was like talking about roof cranes for a
long time and i'm like i wonder if the
woke people like are going to feign
outrage over that
because like i i think the la riots had
a lot of problems we can be critical of
it
but like am i allowed to joke about roof
koreans you know taking their guns and
getting on the rooftops to defend their
families and their businesses
or am i going to get in trouble yeah
you're a racist now as long as you're
making pianos
no you're a racist tim as long as you
make the enemies zombies
then yeah maybe koreans have better aim
it's
racist reminds me that rick and morty
the first episode where he's like shoot
the shoot shoot him morty and he's like
i don't want to kill him he's like
they're robots
and then he shoots one of them and the
guy's like oh my leg
i meant i meant figuratively they're
bureaucrats morty they work for the
government
yeah that was funny i don't think we're
allowed to make that joke yeah work
yeah no i remember when everything
started getting crazy during covet and
the lines were out the door
and it was like all of a sudden like
run-of-the-mill liberals
were trying to buy guns and the funniest
thing about it was how many of them
realized it wasn't easy
like oh no especially in california yeah
i hear it's like
not impossible yeah to buy weapons to
buy a gun in california what's the
process
i hadn't tried because i knew i wasn't
going to be able to do it but i know
that for one the stores were
many of them were closed or if they i
think you have to apply
but um what many of us do is just
we consider going to like my home state
of idaho or nevada
and the process is a lot easier and then
you're able to bring it back to
california oh sure you just have to
register the weapon when you get to
california oh interesting
a lot of states do operate that like
that you know if you already have it or
if you bought it somewhere else
illegally
then they don't care if you have it yeah
so it is weird and
you know in that capacity there are a
lot of people who are staunchly like
absolute to a absolutist and i have to
say from like a legal perspective i
don't see a way around
this argument like you know we we we
talk about michael malus too much
michael we're talking about you too
he's just gonna look that's coming up
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah you can because
romance going you know
it's because he's a smart guy and he
made a really good point he said
that the constitution says i have a
right to keep and bear arms
but every single cop in new york city
would arrest me if i had a gun and i'm
like
i mean the constitution is the law of
the land it says you that the right to
keep and
bear arms shall not be infringed it
doesn't say if you're mentally ill you
can't have a weapon it doesn't say if
you're a felony kind of weapon it
literally is just a verbatim
you can have a weapon yeah i get because
it's the open carry or it's the
concealed carry or open carry laws right
so all of a sudden now there's like look
new jersey you can't
you absolutely you can own the weapon
but you can't
go anywhere with it you can't bear it
well that's right so that's the big
question is what does bear mean
does that yeah but i and i would think
that burying arms
i guess we'd have to look back at what
did they mean by the word bearing
you know bear arms back then it meant
bear on your shoulder
you can kill a bear yeah it looks like
if you're bare naked that means you're
it's obvious everyone can see it um
bearing if you're burying your teeth
that means you're showing your teeth so
bearing your arms would be like open
carry basically well that's what we
think today in 2021 with that word but
i'd be curious to think
what to know what their definition of it
was in 17
you can look at a lot of the quotes from
the founding fathers and like the
federalist papers and things like that
and they're pretty much like
everybody should have guns all the time
right people had people at artillery
you know they had private artillery at
their at their homes there's like a
funny meme about
some you know the the people a lot of
people on the left like to say
the founding fathers didn't expect
someone have a semi-automatic you know
whatever ar-15 assault weapon or
something
um which assault weapon is meaningless
by the way but uh and then there's this
funny meme where it's like
someone breaks into a guy's house and he
pulls out his musket and fires
it it goes across the street and hits a
dog ripping a hole in it because it's
smoothbore
he runs upstairs and screams tally ho
lads and then fires two massive
artillery kits like no no no
people like the the this back in the day
they had private warships
like you could literally own your own
battleship you couldn't own a cannon
you couldn't own a cannon no you
couldn't tone a cannon they actually had
some
believe it or not you know i researched
this extensively because i i was always
a real 2a extreme i would say i was an
extremist
uh back i had and i maybe just barely
converted
out of the extremism but i used to say
if the government can own it
i want to be able to own it yes right
but then i realized there's like i
wouldn't be able to own all the
the weapons the government has because i
don't have enough money and do i really
want the people who are really rich to
have the
ability right and then then i said okay
maybe i'm not so extreme after all
because i don't know if i want the rich
world-class warfare there right i don't
want them to own the nuke
right right but then right and then i
you know bill gates or whoever
right and then the rest of us can't
right mercenary prevents mercenary
warfare in a lot of ways
government oversight crazy as it is yeah
yeah so
you know then i'm less extreme but um
you can own a cannon today
no you can't you you know what i mean
yeah yeah maybe what
what maybe what's the definition i guess
it's a cannon yeah it depends but back
then you couldn't have like an
actual cannon just like they banned
uh fully automatic rifles after the
valentine's day massacres what was that
other than 20s oh actually on
valentine's day
it was yeah i think it was it was a mom
mafia yeah mom hit
went in and killed like 14 or 15. i'm
thinking
maybe because we don't live on the
frontier anymore we don't need
the full open bearing arms mentality
i don't think the canon thing is
accurate i mean i i did i did look it up
and there are people saying you could
not
but privateers and corsairs existed they
and they
maybe if it was like a well-regulated
militia could have a cannon no but a
privateer was like
it literally means private [ __ ] it's
like privateer
yeah yeah they they they're necessarily
pirates but they were responsible for a
lot of the piracy because what would
happen
is uh with with the uk with the with the
english crown for instance they would
issues letters
they would issue letters of mark to a
private warship
or a private ship that had military
capabilities and then the letter of mark
was basically like
if you screw with our enemies then
you're all good
and then what would happen is france
would be like they they'd go to the you
know britain and be like
your your citizens are our pirates and
your signing letters of mark and then
the crown would be like oh
heavens we we they're criminals we had
nothing to do with this
so it was it was it was like mercenary
warfare essentially but people had them
and maybe there's only specific cases
you could have the cannon
like if you had a ship maybe that was it
but you couldn't have one in your
backyard or on your
farm i know today that like uh luke
recently sent me
a um a i guess it was like an artillery
gatling gun of some sort
with like it's got two wheels and it's
this massive thing i sent you a tommy
gun
you're not allowed to have that well not
full auto but you can have it you can
have a tommy gun yeah
um but there's gatling guns are legal
gatling gun's totally legal so each
crank is a trigger pull so you're
allowed to go
and so he's like showing me this like
rotating nine millimeter or whatever
with these huge magazines he's like i
think you should get this and i'm like
bro
i don't think i need i don't think i
need that
oh why not you never know
stephen crowder did like a big thing
about this about what the founding
fathers thought and expected when it
came to weapons and what were available
at the time
and i guess a lot of a lot of people you
know these these liberals who
interestingly now are the ones who are
very much so buying all these weapons
that there were very serious
technological advancements in terms of
firearms back in the day they just
weren't common so while people were
using like flintlock pistols and muskets
and stuff there were
there i think there was one like he
showed where it's got like 16 barrels
and they were each loaded and you could
like fire them all rep in succession and
those were legal and allowed
it's just people it was easier and
cheaper to have the standard
you know single shot or whatever so i
guess
it is an interesting argument about what
they actually thought but
as far as i can tell you know maybe
maybe by today's standards the founding
fathers would look and be like oh
heavens people have
like this yet but hold on
that would that would apply to
everything else too like okay well then
you don't have free speech on social
media you don't you know you're not
allowed to use telephones
because like the the idea that you
aren't allowed to have
your first amendment rights your right
to worship because technology changed
you know well beyond what they expected
to happen communications over the
internet is not guaranteed
and i guess they're arguing that to a
certain extent but
no like technology changes but our
rights change with them so a better
example is probably the fourth amendment
metadata if you you have private
information you do not expect people to
see
then it is a violation of of your your
uh rights
to illegally search and or seize your
private information
there was no such thing as metadata back
then but we still i think for the most
part agree
the nsa is bad you know spying on us and
stealing our data is a violation of our
right to be
free from this intrusion and so
when it comes down to the constitution i
actually think
there are some things that we we don't
want even the state to use against its
people or the people to have because
weapons are becoming extremely powerful
particularly directed energy weapons
cat's out of the bag though there's two
big points the constitution is there
and just because i might not agree with
it i i don't feel like i have the right
to
do you have the right to amend it i have
the right to to express my opinion like
i'm doing now
but i don't i don't believe that these
these politicians who are passing these
laws have a right to do that unless they
amend the constitution
so by all means we can have a
conversation but if you don't get that
two-thirds majority then
it should not be done question is should
we amend it at this point it doesn't
matter
what do you mean 3d printed guns like
there's no stopping but should we have
the right to bear arms
should everyone have the explicit right
to walk around with the open carry
weapon
yup even in a city where you're packed
together and it's like
20 30 people sitting on a bus and
everyone's got a handgun yep
very polite maybe not a handgun oh yeah
i think so you think so
everything anything i really i think you
could have like really
what about if a little kid had one what
about if a kid reached over and grabbed
your gun or something
that's theft but it was a kid it didn't
know any better what would you do
what if like someone's four-year-old
reached over and tried to grab your gun
then take better care of your gun and
just out of your holster just reach over
and grab
that you'd grab are you you can't
overpower 11 year old ian
i'm saying so long as the constitution
says you have the right to keep and bear
arms
i can't tell someone they can't do it i
know but should we change the
constitution was my question
like do you think there should be
training for guns you know this is like
one
maybe a lot saying okay you can yes
absolutely you can but what about if we
said okay you can bear it
publicly as long as you've passed
training courses
the the i i don't like that idea why not
i guess the challenge is so long as the
constitution has it
verbatim in there i feel like it would
be
an authoritarian violation of other
people's rights to supersede the supreme
law of this land
that includes all of the amendments as
well like fifth amendment fourth
amendment third i don't think we have to
worry about the third amendment because
troops aren't gonna be coming to our
houses but yeah you know whatever i
don't know that i mean look what they're
doing
i know for real third amendment might be
covered no might become important
i i used to actually think more along
the lines of
there's probably reasonable restrictions
we can put in place
and you know much like the first
amendment i think there are some
reasonable interpretations
don't commit a crime so with the first
amendment we have a right to free speech
freedom of assembly religion the press
and a region of grievances
and those are all fairly straightforward
and we know what they can do and what we
can do
and if someone commits a crime by
instructing or inciting violence that is
not protected
in fact it says peaceably assemble and
so that i understand
that's not in my opinion a restriction
on the first amendment which says speech
and and reason
and peaceably assemble if you are
committing a crime there is a challenge
because crimes can
cr laws can be changed and other things
can become crimes they can say
okay if you one of the arguments to be
careful of and this is why
i'm i'm still very much more absolute on
free speech issues not completely though
is they'll say all right if committing a
crime is the threshold by which
you don't have the right to say
something like telling someone to go
commit
harm or murder somebody charles manson
then what if they pass a law saying hate
speech is a crime and now they can say
okay well now that offending someone is
a crime you can't cross the threshold of
committing a crime so it's
it's very difficult and that's why the
constitution exists for
an important reason the founding fathers
were very concerned about tyranny
more so the bill of rights was the
anti-federalists who are concerned that
centralization of federal authority
would cause another situation like they
had with the crown
so we got these guaranteed rights if you
want them to change
we have an amendment process for this so
as much as i might be like
in chicago we got gun problems in new
york
if you know we had when we were talking
with luke about this it was interesting
because i said
bro if you're in a cubicle apartment
stacked on top of a bunch of concrete
shoe boxes smelling like sour milk
and someone breaks in and you've got you
know like a 308 rifle
you're going to go through the walls you
might hit somebody that's really bad and
luke's instinctive reaction was maybe we
ban you know
maybe we don't allow certain calibers i
was like oh there it is it's exactly
exactly the logic people use and i
totally understand it
if you're in new york and someone tries
robbing you and you pull your gun
you can cause a lot of collateral damage
because you're
prob you'll probably miss people don't
realize even people who are good at
shooting might be in an intense
situation
they're they panic they miss they hit
something they hit somebody else
so naturally people in big cities say we
want gun control laws
my problem is okay but you need to amend
the constitution
we can't just say the constitution is
meaningless because either it matters or
it doesn't
and i do not believe that i
have the authority or any politician
does to be like constitution doesn't
matter i guess that's why we don't why
the constitution says anyone can do it
and then it's like a state by state or
locality by locality
thing because you don't want to ban the
open right to carry in
you know rural idaho when just because
of new york city is too clo people are
too close together
yeah but we don't do that with free
speech we don't say well it's based on
which city you live in
so you know you should have the right to
say what you want to say if you're in
rural idaho but not if you're in new
york city i mean we you know so on that
point
we don't have it municipality by
municipality we do it
you know it's a blanket free speech
maybe the issue is just
listen you're responsible for whatever
comes at the end of that barrel and if
you live in new york and you own a gun
and you have it on you and you use it
and whatever it hits you're responsible
for
the same is true for anywhere you live
yeah but if i'm dead i'm not gonna care
how responsible you were held
to whatever it was right like at that
point i'm already
i've already been victimized or i've
already had to
take the bullet literally and you maybe
get punished but what does that do
to help me and i think that's why you
know they make these laws because
they're trying to prevent
from me ever having that situation not
it's not about
you won't get punished it's about i
won't be victimized
it's a it's a it's it's an ethical
conundrum to say the least
and uh man we just really love really
love making sure everybody knows who
michael malus is
yeah i hope you talk about me as well
you know as much
as i got
[Laughter]
i'm going to be listening every day and
if i don't hear my name at least three
times a show
my rights are not up to a vote and i'm
like
man he's got but they are aren't they
you can vote to amend the constitution
and change people's rights
so the issue is yes but i think the the
the simple simple way to look at it is
so long as the constitution guarantees
your right to bear arms to keep them
then then it needs to be all the states
coming together and changing that
and not some rep kinzinger in illinois
being like i think we should have
expanded background checks banning the
private sale of firearms so do you
agree with banning certain weapons or
all weapons
from those who've committed absolutely
not
so even those who've committed violent
crime
with weapons and then they get out of
jail they pay their debt to society
and so you think they should be allowed
to own a weapon again yes
even those who committed violent crime
with a gun they're out of prison
yeah so they pay the debt to society
well maybe they should be allowed to
vote
they should i agree they should be
allowed they should get all of their
rights reinstated
all of them including wow the right to
bear on i don't know i hadn't thought
about that i mean i definitely think
felons who've who've paid their price
and have come out should have the right
restored to
vote and bear arms and travel everything
yeah everything except i don't know
about
whether or not you know domestic
violence you know especially guys that
have committed acts of domestic violence
they go in they come out
and they serve very little time and then
you know so not everybody does pay
what i would consider a reasonable debt
to society it is better that ten guilty
persons escaped than one innocent person
suffer
i will take the the liberty-based view
that we must protect the the rights of
the individual
the and and those who have done right by
our system and our rules
over fear that there may be a risk like
uh it we mentioned this the other day i
think it was otto von bismarck or
whatever who said it is better that 10
innocent people suffer than one guilty
person escape somebody who's suicidal
what do you think should they have the
right to bear arms yes
even if you know i'm in favor of
assisted suicide
yeah but this is different than assisted
suicide this is somebody who's
um you know down they're feeling very
down they they're not seeing the
the light at the end of the tunnel right
they're feeling and
this is something that could be
corrected fixed but not if they have a
shotgun
not if they have a butter knife but i
agree with you on a you know on uh
physician-assisted suicide for sure that
has you see the uh the dark knight
you know the little batman movie yeah
joker made a pencil disappear
you know that scene it's a very brutal
scene where he goes into the mobsters
and
they're like what do you want he's like
i'm going to show you i'm doing a magic
trick and he's oh right
i'm going to make it disappear and then
he slams the guy's head into it the
pencil's gone
the reason i bring that up is like if
somebody if somebody's determined to
cause themselves harm and end their life
what they need is help and
one of the reasons i'm in favor of
assisted suicide is not because i'm like
yes someone should just help them die
it's because they'll talk to somebody
first
they'll go through a process to make
sure they actually it's actually
something that should happen
and oftentimes a lot of people might
have a chronic disease or like cluster
headaches
where their life is just pure psychotic
misery and agony and they're desperate
nothing will relieve their pain
oftentimes they're going through a
period of depression and it'll put it'll
help them go through therapy as opposed
taking their taking their taking action
on their own
the the gun argument for suicide
overlooks the fact that people will
get drunk and then sink into a bathtub
or they'll take pills and then sink into
a bathtub
drop a toaster in the bathtub and a
bunch of other really awful things
well i don't know i think you know for a
lot of people there they maybe want to
end their life but they want to do it
quick and easy and they can't
fathom doing it in some you know drawn
out way that's going to cause
a lot more pain or harm they want
something quick
right it does and it and it is the
number one you know when people talk
about
all the gun violence right whenever
they're mentioning all the gun violence
all these things it's mostly suicide
that's true
and so that's true so maybe there should
be some sort of provision where it is
like a seven
year you know that's what california
does seven years you can't own a weapon
after ever been suicidal or an attempt
right after for seven years i think
that's way too long
way too long yeah it might be long yeah
that might be a bit prison's intense
though
the way our prison structure is is it
makes people radicalize
oh absolutely the most part so a gun
violent a violent gun offender goes in
there comes out
there's a good chance that he he or she
is crazier than they were when they went
in so
the the main issue with the suicide
thing is i'll put it this way i would
absolutely love it
if there was a way to reasonably have
someone who was suicidal not have access
to
a gun or something they could use to end
their life one of the reasons i'm in
favor of assisted suicide is that
we want to encourage as many people to
go to go to a doctor and for therapy
to talk about why they feel this way and
determine if it actually is something
they should
they need most people oh so you mean
you're for physician-assisted suicide
even if the person's healthy
and they want to end their life no no no
i'm saying it would encourage people who
are suicidal to go to a doctor
and the doctor would be like no you know
what i mean
i don't know if i mean if they unless
they were led to believe that that was
an
option like if i can go to my doctor and
i could tell them i'm suicidal i don't
want to do this anymore help me
yeah yeah but that's different than like
well so there would be criteria but i do
believe there are a lot of people who
would be like my life sucks i'm
miserable and i think i might qualify
they'll go to a doctor
whatever we can have to be crazy and
suicidal i think
i think it's it's it may not be a
perfect solution but whatever we can do
to encourage people who are suffering to
go to a doctor in any capacity right
right so
i would love it if we could be like okay
let's they can't if they're dead because
they've shot themselves because we'll
let them have a gun then how do you
take away their gun before they were
suicidal before you knew they were
supposed to well you didn't right so
they
had the option at that point and so
we're not not it's definitely not going
to cure the problem
well because people usually reach out at
some point prior to that point i mean
most people don't
really want to end their life and so
they go through a process of reaching
out before they get to that point so the
people around them know
and then they can say we're going to
take the weapon you're talking just if
they've attempted suicide
no or they've reached out and said i'm
not you know because they go through a
process
prior to even hitting that point there
was a there was a story i think this was
in maryland i'm not sure it might have
been baltimore area
where there was a guy he was in his 60s
i could be getting some of the details
wrong but
the gist of it was someone in his life
an axe or a family member was feuding
with him
told the police that he was unstable and
unwell and armed
and so they served a red flag warrant
the police hoped to his house and he had
no idea why they were there
they knock on the door and he answers
the door and he's got his gun
which he's legally allowed to do and
they said
we are taking your gun and he doesn't
know why
and he said the hell you are and he
fought with them and they shot and
killed him
the problem with trying to seize
someone's weapons because
we think they might be suicidal is that
we create conflicts where someone with a
gun is now going to be engaging with
police
we don't want the conflict so it is
tough i'm not saying like you know if
there's
if there's someone who's like deranged
and mentally unwell
and they've got a gun like we definitely
want to prevent
them from going on you know killing
spree or doing something really
atrocious
with it with that weapon and figuring
out the right way to go about doing that
is difficult because red flag laws end
up creating very dangerous circumstances
and may actually end up backfiring like
they did in this circumstance and
there's apparently a bunch of other
stories that are similar to
this this actually happened in colorado
this happened to someone that i'm
tertiarily connected to um he was a
lawyer he knew his rights he was former
military he was armed
they served a red flag on him and it
ended in his death because he barricaded
himself in there and there was no
getting him out without i mean you gotta
you gotta think about this too if like
these people really are
unstable then you're going to send in
police to be like now give us your guns
when they're already on stage
right then they're going to that's going
to be a great way for them to commit
suicide right then and there right there
there is logic here right especially
there is logic here like we want to make
sure these crazy psychopaths don't have
access to these weapons
you know and they can't do these things
but i don't know how you do that i
really really don't
criminals get guns and they're easy ways
to get guns no matter what we do
when they ban things people just find a
way and more importantly
3d printed guns yeah you can get a 3d
printer for a couple hundred bucks
and you can easily print like what was
the one we've been talking about right
now that the first one
the ghost gun that first one the first
thing's called the liberator the
liberator
did you only get one shot with those
yeah the original ones about one but
they've improved it and now apparently
there's some like
like better designs that can withstand
and actually get a few rounds
you could easily 3d print something fgc
no not until then
gun control they're going to change the
uh the tech
on the printers to prevent them from
being able to print a gun
and the way they do that is by trying to
hide the information or make the
information illegal
it won't work which is why the social
networking censoring thing is so
desperate you you can't you can't do it
i mean the cad files are on the dark web
absolutely not not even not even just
about people they might be able to put
back doors in the machines but you can
build your own 3d printers too i don't
know i doubt that anyone could ever have
total control every
every time a new iphone update comes out
some like
17 year old kid figures out how to break
apple security right and then you can
install whatever you want
so i think more importantly is like my
ideal version of a world is people have
a reasonable uh
armament people who are mentally ill or
suicidal
aren't armed we have restrictions to
make sure that the people who have
weapons are
intelligent well trained well informed
the first problem i encounter is the
constitution
it doesn't say what the qualifications
are just as if people have a right to do
it and we need to have
an amendment if we want that to be
considered and then beyond that is how
do you actually implement any of these
controls without actually just
infringing on the rights of those who
are intelligent
well-meaning to lawful citizens because
i grew up in chicago where guns were
like they're basically illegal
and every criminal has one like i i i
i was a high school fight i was 14 a
couple blocks from my house
and some 15 year old kid had a gun they
can just get it
so easily and so all that really ends up
happening is that
no one anywhere nearby had any means of
protecting themselves from this person
who had a gun
and so you get a lot of murders on the
south side and there's nothing anyone
can do because they're not legally
allowed to defend themselves when they
see it
maybe it wouldn't be a perfect world
having a very dense population and
everyone being armed because people
might panic and you get a lot more
shootings
but what's the alternative i i don't
know what what that world would look
like i do know the world we have now is
in chicago
there was a a friend of a friend of mine
uh
he wasn't someone i knew but it was
someone my friends were friends with
took two in the chest because he was
sitting in front of the wrong house in
his car and that was it
someone walked out and and had a gun and
they couldn't do anything and he went
pop-pop
well i definitely think and kind of back
to one of my original points is that
um we can curb gun violence
by creating a happy population and when
people feel like they're happy and they
have opportunity
and they've got a good life in front of
them they don't turn to violence and
crime
when we know this this is why we're
seeing an uptick a major uptick right
now
in violent crime murders i think are up
30 percent
in the entire country over 30 maybe 38
percent i think was the last doubt i
read
and that is because obvi you know people
without jobs people without opportunity
people
struggling and the police have been
defunded well
in many of these cities yeah on top of
it so i think um
but even if they weren't i think we'd
still see the uptick because people are
feeling more desperate and we are all
animals at our core
i don't think any of us are better than
anybody we all can revert
to that animalistic side of us and so i
think that if we want to curb
gun violence probably one of the better
measures because you look at a country
like switzerland where everybody's got a
gun
um and they have very little gun
violence but they're all very happy
and they're all cared for they are a
happy population they don't feel like
they have to
resort to any of that i think the the
main issue is
i'm going to avoid using the principal
buzzword because i know it'll trigger
the left but uh
i'll just say we have disparate cultures
in this country
and that means uh actually let me i
didn't get triggered only because i
don't know what that means
don't use fancy words with me tim so
what is what does multiculturalism mean
to you multiculturalism
multiple cultures and so american
culture
how would you define american culture
multicultural
well i mean that seems to be like i
guess kind of paradise
circular logic or paradoxical i don't
think
well you know in my world there isn't an
american culture
that's like i think what maybe others
would think of as american culture like
i think they think of
you know cheeseburgers i think they
think of like my dad's life
where my dad grew up in idaho you know
on a farm
with um blonde hair blue eyes
you know went to church people just had
pigs or something
does your mom believe in free speech
yeah but so that's why to me
american culture is different right
because i'm an american and i was raised
here but my mom is vietnamese and my
mom's side of the family's vietnamese
and they're very american i mean my mom
is a big trump supporter
um ironically you know my dad's side of
the family
idahoans farmers not they were bernie
total progress very similar experience
it's very strange
like yeah the korean side of my family
is it's not entirely trump but you know
it's more interestingly yeah and my
mom's side of the family
these are the refugees that by the way
went through some of those camps that
you have to go through in order to
process they went through the processing
centers
um and uh people of color you know
living in california
and they're the big trump supporters
they're they're uh the idea of
multiculturalism has two meanings
to the progressives it means that under
this big shared
human experience we all have different
ways of living different clothes and
different ways of speaking
but all of these cultures can exist side
by side you think so that that's what
liberals think i don't think so i don't
think so no
well you said progressive you said
liberal oh
well there's an overlap between the two
i mean no i don't think progressives
feel that way about multiculturalism
no i don't think that's that's what they
want multiple no what do you what do you
think they mean by it because they
cancel all of that
it's like you're not allowed to be
different right no no well they
segregate it
they well so it's it's it's it's like a
honeycomb of like your culture goes here
and ours go here and we don't interact
bernie sanders was like the penultimate
progressive he would he's not at all
like that he's
so like loving of all people no no he
went upstairs
yeah he went on stage and said white
people don't know what it's like to be
poor yeah he changed
he fell into the idea 2016 bernie so i'm
a 2016
bernie that's my life 2020 bernie he
turned into aoc and i think that's
actually what he did he saw her
and how popular she was and becoming and
i think he adopted a lot of her rhetoric
and it was a mistake
same with like trump had he just stuck
with his 2016 campaign message
and had bernie stuck with this 2016
campaign message both of them
right it would have been a very
different outcome i love this this fact
check from politifact
bernie sanders when you're white you
don't know what it's like to be poor and
they say
false and i think it's funny just
because like it's such a weird thing to
say
like of course why people know it's like
to be poor and it's also like how do you
actually prove what white people
know because you can't read their minds
but we all just know
they do know what it's like to be poor
it's a weird thing to fact check because
it's kind of just like well it's common
sense if a white person is poor they
probably know this
why would bernie say that on march 6
2016 he said that
when you're like don't know what's like
global poverty and he's assuming that
most of the white people
he didn't say that no he did say it he's
false about it
they're saying his statement is is false
oh that's what oh they're saying his
statement bernie sanders did say this
wow
so he said quote when you're white you
don't know what it's like to be living
in a ghetto
you don't know what it's like to be poor
you don't know what it's like to be
hassled when you walk down the street or
you get dragged out of a car sander said
when you're white you don't know what
it's like to be poor politifact rates
this statement as a false statement
i think it's funny because you can't
read the minds of white people
and assume they know what it's like to
be poor but considering the fact that
white poor people
are the they're more white poor people
than any other you know demographic
then it's fairly obvious bernie would
like he got arrested for sitting on
civil rights
in his early days but he was co-opted by
this progressive mind bug
bro he stopped saying millionaires he
still i heard him say it a couple weeks
ago well there as soon as he became a
millionaire there was it was it was
it was a progressive outs outlet that
mentioned this too i can't remember
which one
they were like you can i think it may
have been like axios or something that's
not super progressive
which is like kind of mainstream left
they said you can track the moment when
bernie sanders became a millionaire by
when he stopped saying millionaires and
billionaires and began only saying
billionaires
and then you can actually look at the
chart and see it in a way is right
because it's the billionaire class
that's like
choosing global policy 999 million
dollar errors
you don't have a lot of those at davos i
mean you might but most of those people
are like
multi billionaire worth 20 billion 50
billion
i was i was i was at the world economic
forum a couple years ago a lot of people
who are not rich
who are totally on board with everything
they're doing yeah and are all about
this but are there were you like
choosing global policy were you
not invited into the back rooms yeah i
was invited to a ski resort to like hang
out
like cities and i mean maybe
millionaires do too not
every single person who's invited in has
that level of wealth some people are
just famous
so even if you have 500 million you're
still living at the same level as a
billionaire in a lot of ways and you can
see
lifestyle but it's a very different
lifestyle than 10 million right
oh yeah and and 10 billion you'd have
like 50 companies if you were at 10
billion dollars with 500 million maybe
like three
two four but i think they're living a
similar lifestyle how many yachts can
you have you know
it's i i would say not necessarily
there's a certain amount of money where
you can completely influence
politics to an insane degree but let's
go back a little bit you know because
we're talking a little bit about bernie
but i do want to mention the
multiculturalism thing because we're
talking about
switzerland and gun crime and stuff and
the issue is they're extremely
culturally homogenous
i don't know if that i that i hate that
argument
i went to sweden and i was told by all
of these people on the right that there
was a serious crime wave from refugees
and migrants i was told on the left it
was not true
that crime was worse among native swedes
and things like that
it turns out the right-wing narrative
was particularly exaggerated
i don't think from many of the
conservatives it was intentional
i think what happened was there was a
crime wave happening in some cities
notably malma
and they saw their murder rates spike by
like 1
300 percent that's shocking this is true
right
murder and moma year over year went went
up
300 percent now when conservatives heard
that they were like
jeez what is happening in this place
well they recently took a bunch of
refugees that must be the issue
it went from one murder to 13 murders it
was the children of
of refugees and migrants from
20-something years ago
and even maybe the grandchildren and the
crime was gang-related
not refugees from the middle east and it
was one murder to 13 murders
so while it was a massive percentage
increase when you realize like okay that
is bad
but their crime is still ridiculously
low relative to anybody else
we definitely don't want crime on the
rise but a lot of people in the united
states in the uk hear that and they
imagine the cities are burning down and
it's like this massive increase in crime
and then many on the left just like out
like outright denied that it was
happening
what i ended up finding out when i went
to sweden was that
when they brought in a lot of somali
refugees in the 90s they put them in
enclaves where they had almost no
opportunity to integrate with the
swedish economy
it's not about culture it's not about
language it's about the ability to get a
job and if you can't get a job
you become poor and if you're poor you
become a poverty breeds crime
what ended up happening was i was told
by many people in sweden
that these young men in places in some
of these places
uh rosengard or whatever that
they're they're called immigrants by
people in sweden even though they were
born in the country
if they go and visit their relatives in
somalia they're called swedes
because they have accents and they're
not from somalia so here they are people
who struggle to find work who can't find
work and are and are
basically isolated from swedish culture
because of the racism of sweden sweden
is one of the most racist place i've
ever been to mind you absolutely
these people can't get jobs they turn to
lives of crime out of desperation and
disdain they don't view the police as
having any authority over them because
they don't feel like they're a part of
that community
because they were raised as being told
they were immigrants when they were born
in the country
that lack of integration and that
separation of their two cultures
means they didn't care about the swedish
people and the swedish people certainly
didn't care about them
they changed the policy recently uh this
is years ago mind you but they changed
the policy when i was there
so that when new migrants refugees were
refugees were coming in they were
strategically placed
so that they were absolutely placed into
the economy
with an opportunity to work and go to
school and have jobs and that seemed to
have been helping a lot of the issues
what ended up happening was there's a
couple different ways we can experience
multiculturalism
but the idea that's being pushed by the
left as you noted the segregation
idea is going to result in serious crime
and violence
and so you'll have people who own guns
and they'll use them against those who
are not a part of their community
the i think the easiest way to
understand it there's there's a saying
that
that many activists have snitches get
stitches i think a lot of people say
that
and you're also not supposed to cross
the thin blue line or what you know
whatever that saying is
there are many instances where we have
seen police officers commit crimes
and then the other cops will lie to
protect them i know this firsthand
because there was a guy
in new york who was falsely accused of a
crime i happen to have been live
streaming and filmed it
and the officer who grabbed the the
supervisor who grabbed the guy
instructed a different cop to lie on her
arrest documents about what he did and
she did it no problem
and she went to court and lied under
oath no problem and then the defense
said
here's the footage proving you lied and
they said officer you're free to go have
a nice day case dismissed
and they asked no no no one seemed to
care these cops just did this
at the same time antifa will go around
throwing explosives at people
and left-wing activists in portland will
lie and shield them to protect them
people in certain communities do not rat
on their own they never do and they tell
you not to do it
during occupy wall street there were
several women who were assaulted
inside the zuccotti park camp and they
explicitly told everyone don't tell the
police it happened
because then the cops will come in and
we'll have to deal with them smearing us
so we'll take care of it ourselves what
happened those those men who were
abusing those women
in the tents while holding them down and
just really awful stuff got away with it
because they didn't want to look bad
they didn't want their community to be
harmed they would not
turn on people inside the camps so the
the issue i i see here is that we want
integration and we want shared cultures
and experiences
but as you noted the the modern
progressives are
segregating and canceling everybody who
do these kinds of things you know
you're culturally appropriating if you
you know try to mix
in but i think that you know that's not
a homogenous i don't know if like
switzerland for example has a low crime
rate because they're homogenous
the reason i have an issue with that
argument is because i don't think it has
anything to do with homogeneity it has
everything to do with what you pointed
out really was classism
so it's that they they're all in the
same class right so they're economically
all
having all kinds of opportunity so in
sweden had they given the opportunity to
those groups
and not and i don't even think you need
to actually integrate them in to give
them that opportunity and the vietnamese
community which is my community
is a good example of that vietnamese
people yeah
well well in some ways vietnamese people
have
largely segregated themselves they
prefer to live together in one community
like little saigon down in orange county
they prefer it they'll commute hours
just to go back home and live in their
community so they actually sort of
self-segregate
but because they had opportunity and the
ability to go and start businesses and
the ability to thrive
there's very little crime now but when i
was a kid growing up
how many times did i see was i victim of
home burglarizing home home invasion my
grandmother was a home invasion victim
where they tied her up
meet her up for like four hours that was
going on in my community
in the vietnamese community when there
was a lack of opportunity or
i would say not lack of opportunity
because the opportunity was there
it's just that they were still poor i i
think i think you're right and
i'll amend my statement i think there
are issues where communities don't hold
their own accountable
but i do think poverty was the driving
force yeah looking at what's happening
what was happening in sweden it was
specifically because the children of
these migrants
couldn't get work right and so you had a
poor community that was desperate and
also kind of shunned
and that you know that breeds crime and
then the community factor kind of plays
a role in this as well so
how do you feel about universal basic
income
you know i don't know how i feel about
it yet so
i was a big andrew yang fan too you know
i like them and stuff and i so i don't
want to say no to it but i'm also not
ready to buy into the idea yet do you
think that it would
help people break the class barrier and
it's hard to say right because or a
landlord says i know now you've gotten a
thousand extra dollars a month
so now i'm going to raise the rent i
mean so that's kind of my
when the when especially in a society
that we are in which is capitalist
society right
if the people know that you have the
means and the ability to pay they will
raise the price this is what
we the problem we actually the
fundamental problem we have with banks
is that banks will say well um like this
is why
student education i think has gone
through the roof is because when the
government said especially we'll do
federally backed student loans
then the banks are like well then you
know we'll go ahead and uh give you a
bunch of loans
and um and you know and and then the
institutions were like well wow
okay then we'll go ahead and um uh raise
the price of tuition because we know
you're going to get the loan it's a
guarantee
right it's guaranteed money right they
were able to just continue raising and
raising and raising
and so that's my that's my one concern
with
the universal basic income is that it
would create that same sort well you
have federal guaranteed money
and so therefore i know what i can do in
response is raise
prices yeah right that that's actually a
good point people don't bring up
there's talk about inflation you know if
if the average working person
if you know uh their labor is valued
less
or or uh or it's more expensive now
because they already have access to
you know resources and revenue then how
the price of everything is going to go
up
it's a weird thing that i think a lot of
progressives don't seem to understand
when it comes to the arguments about
minimum wage
i i used to be a a pretty good pretty
big proponent of increasing it to a
certain extent
slow rolled increase and then i
literally met an accountant
for my business and i asked him and i
talked to
a couple different accountants they were
all democrats you know in in the blue
areas in the philly area
they all basically said the same thing
yeah uh like 30 of my clients lost their
business when the when the minimum wage
went up
because you might increase the wages for
these people but that doesn't mean the
business has the money to pay them
and if they don't if they're operating
on a skeleton crew staff already as a
small business
all of a sudden their liabilities jump
30
employment taxes and wages because it's
all of the employees
but their money in the bank stays the
same so all of a sudden
overnight they're insolvent they're gone
right so it
didn't work you know there's um and i
you know and i have
um mixed feelings too about you know i
so i'm naturally
by default you know a leftist so i
automatically okay raise minimum wage
fine
sounds good everybody's on board but i
think there's another way to do it
that's actually more effective and would
resolve that problem and it would be to
tie
wages to the highest paid person in the
organization
and germany what they do there is
everyone can see what everybody makes in
an organization
so at bmw for example everybody knows
what everybody is making
there they tell every they know
everybody knows where they're at
and they all know how they can get
raises and it's like you could have a
janitor at bmw making more money than
somebody who's at a different job but
that's because the janitor's been there
for 20 years
and it's a set system and everybody
knows and it's all understood
and so then when you find out somebody's
making a certain amount of money because
it's extremely transparent
you don't have any questions of why you
know you know why they're making the
money that they're making
but i think that there's a way to tie
and you know you know who else does that
who does transparent wages
is whole foods i believe everybody at
whole foods knows what everybody makes
and there's a couple of other companies
that do it but i think if you tie the
wage
to a percentage of whatever the top
person is making
i'm gonna have to shatter that beautiful
dream of yours
don't why why that's what he does
so uh profit
passive income it's it's amazing uh
you could do something very clever you
could be the ceo of a multi-million
dollar company with a million dollar
salary
and then announce to the world that you
know what
wealth inequality in this country is
wrong i am lowering my salary
to what did harvard say harvard said you
need like 77 000
or whatever to be happy 80 000 and then
i'm gonna use that money to give
everybody a raise
and then you you give your employees a
raise and everyone's like look at this
guy who's a bastion of good left
libertarianism was really helping
and then you look at your bottom line
and you're like okay so i took off
about 920 000 of my salary
which was taxed at the employment rate
which is 7.5 on mine and 7.5 on the
business end
now that it's passive income i save 7.5
and make way more money congratulations
you found a way to make
70 plus grand while pretending to lower
your wage
company it could also be tied to the
revenue of the company
so you could tie it all together so
there could be a system where it's like
okay you know the the well like in japan
and in germany for example it's really
immoral for ceos to get paid a certain
amount of money it's a it's a cultural
enforcement
a social interest right well yeah so
here's the here's the here's the issue
uh with tying it to revenue one of one
of the difficult things too about
running a business is when you have to
it's a really really weird thing at the
end of the year when depending on kind
of business you have you have to pay
taxes on the money but you need that
money to operate
and so it's kind of frustrating where
it's like you might have a good month
and you're like this is wonderful
i have enough that's like a safety net
to make sure my company can function
and now i have to give a chunk of that
to the government but it's like all that
happened was a day passed
you know so if if one of one of the
hardest things is
when if you try tying revenue to the
highest paid person
what happens if you bring in a good
amount of revenue and you want to expand
and invest and grow the company and hire
more people
well you can't now because you made too
much you got to pay everyone a lot more
money
could you then defer it by saying wait
i'm not going to pay them more money
more money because i'm
actually going to hire 10 more people
and create 10 more jobs which
lowers our well it doesn't lower your
revenue it lowers your
it increases your expenses and lows your
profits
so do you have it be tied to the profit
well then someone can just
i'm giving myself a uh you know an ir a
bonus
i'm going to be giving myself a cd as an
executive bonus which is not income that
can be taken today
there's there's we're adding in one ways
to to get around this stuff
i actually don't think you can get
around it with the passive income thing
now that i'm thinking more about it if
if um
they would make a rule that the owner
could not so not so you couldn't be the
owner
so it would be the highest so and the
highest paid employee versus the lowest
paid employee
right so the owner is not and they
already do this with the corporations as
it is you know there's so many
and you know i know all this sounds
really complicated but as it is come on
our taxes are so complicated we could
just ex
you know make some extra complications
to this it's not that big of a deal
but i think that they could say exempt
from owner you know there's like
just like right now with pass through
corporations they've got
certain things where they say okay but
if you're an owner then you don't get
this tax break but if you are you know
that might work the highest paid
employee versus the lowest paid employee
and shareholders are exempt the owners
yeah
so then basically yeah shareholders yeah
if you have somebody who's like an
executive
you know you know executive vice
president or something
and they're like i'll only do this job
for a million dollars a year
and then you're like okay well that
means we got to pay the lowest paid
employee you know like 50 000 a year
right then that's actually really good
for the business owner because you can
then say
sorry i can't give you a million dollars
because then i'd have to pay the
the mail room guy 50k a year and we
can't afford that we've got a thousand
low-level employees that would have to
go up
substantially if we gave you that much
money so it actually is a great
bargaining chip for the uh for the
business owners to essentially be like
we can keep down i think that actually
could theoretically result in
a dramatic split between the wealth of
the classes
because the owners would then have in
effect a legal
coordination to stop paying people more
money
well and also it would well for one it
would that's a bad thing by the way
yeah i i know how you're creating growth
and new employees like you'd rather have
more employees than paying
singular employees this way there are a
lot of people who are not business
owners who get paid lots and lots of
money
well if the owner says listen if i give
you that high salary
then it's actually going to increase the
total company's cost can't do it we
can't do it sorry no you can do it
if you really value that person you want
to hire so if you say listen this is the
best ceo i could get to run my
corporation and
and now my business is at that level
where i need that guy
to come in and run this thing but he's
demanding 50 million dollars to be the
ceo of my corporation
then i think it's worth the investment
you know then you calculate this in and
you say
so we're bringing it in because we're
successful
we're able to bring in this guy who's
successful he's only going to make us
more successful
i i see what you're saying i'd imagine
if somebody was paying a ceo of 50
million dollars we're talking about like
an amazon tier company where bezos he
actually only gets 83 000 a year
because you know he's a billionaire from
stock but if someone if someone brought
on a ceo at 50 million
we're talking like probably 50k
employees or something or a decent
amount of them probably
at the lowest level so that would mean
that you're going to say 50 million
a year plus all of these costs let's say
25 000 people and we're going to
increase
you know you know per employee 10 000
now is it really feasible to pay all
that money you know
that's why you'd have to really decide
if that person was really truly worth it
and and you'd have to it couldn't just
be your buddy you're trying to give a
good job to
it would have to be that person is
actually going to bring value to your
company you believe they're going to
bring value to your company and so you
think they're worse
worth that entire investment otherwise
you tone it down a bit on who you can
hire
twenty five thousand times ten thousand
what is that two uh 250 million
is that am i doing my math wrong yeah i
don't know but i mean we wouldn't
necessarily say
i should be a wizard but we wouldn't
necessarily say that that's the amount
of money right
i mean so you'd set it in a way that it
makes sense and some smart accountants
would sit down and actually
maybe maybe it just gives every you know
hourly employee another
50 seconds i think it's two points or
maybe it ends up giving them all 25
bucks an hour
what was the numbers 20 25 an hour yeah
maybe like who knows what it does right
but if we said
this is the way we're going to do it
from now on and the highest paid
employee cannot make
all of the money at the company i
certainly think we have a wealth
inequality problem and i talk about it
you know every so often
the issue is you end up with the george
soros's and the and the bezos and the
mercers and just really really wealthy
people 250 million 20 million you end up
with extremely wealthy people who have
all of the power and then we're supposed
to be a government of fi
of buy-in for the people but let's be
real man
a regular citizen's vote is near
meaningless and we all know it
and i don't i don't mean to discourage
people i mean your votes are very
important you make sure you go out vote
what i mean is
relative to the power of a billionaire
who can fund
you know just dump money in the pockets
via super pac or by
by just you know direct donation to
every single candidate they want
and you know we know that the studies
have shown that
the public opinion has no impact on on
policy
it is the donor class the wealthy
individuals who control everything
we should not be a country that does
that and i think it's one of the reasons
you end up with a bernie sanders on the
left and a trump on the right
so i certainly think we need to figure
this out and one of the reasons i've
talked about why i support
very very high tax brackets for the
ultra wealthy
well let me explain though because
there's some caveats here the general
idea is
if you make a hundred thousand dollars a
year you're pretty it's pretty good man
you're doing all right i mean covet has
really messed everything up so it's
probably need more than that at this
point
but if you're spending you know 37 of
that in taxes
how much money do you have left over to
live not enough to live a middle-class
life according to that harvard business
study so you'd have to make maybe like
150k
to clear 80k spending so you can have
vacation a family and food
but what if you make a million dollars a
year now your tax bracket's higher
but you still have hundreds of thousands
of dollars left over
after your base expenses eventually
people using this money can invest
can grow more and power attracts power
and it's a snowball rolling and rolling
downhill where they gain more and more
and more wealth
then at a certain point you have people
who really what i call it breaking the
barrier
reach that point of independent wealth
where they no longer have to work they
have so much money
and i don't mean like you can live off
the money and retire i mean quite
literally
they can put it in the bank and generate
so much interest they just don't have to
work
that is a problem because then that
massive amount of wealth and power
means they can just control whatever
they want they can shut down the
opinions of a good working class
american
some some you know middle class family
in the middle of the country
a mom and a dad who are working to make
ends meet and they see something on the
news and they say
i think i should be allowed to defend my
family if a burglar comes and i want the
right to bear arms
and then some random dude with a worth
you know a couple billion dollars just
laughs and says
too bad i as a single individual am
going to pour so much money into all of
the candidates who want to ban guns that
your opinion is meaningless
and i'm like why should that one person
supersede those two people simply based
on how much money he has
they're certainly just about free speech
and you're right to buy commercials and
stuff
i like the idea of a progressive tax
because the more power you have the more
power you can gain and a progressive tax
slowly starts to chip away at how much
you're really gaining there's a limit
though to figure that limit out so i'm
not entirely sure i don't think it's 90
percent like some people have suggested
maybe 55 60 for the highest income
earners i'm talking like over 5 million
a year
the main issue as to why milton's fences
are here i don't think it can be
implemented is
it makes no sense to just give that
money to the government to go blow up
kids in syria so
we want to curtail the ultra elites from
shutting down our rights and shutting
down our free speech
zuckerberg dumped what 300 million into
the election meanwhile he's censoring
our speech on facebook and twitter
i don't like these billionaires having
all of that power but i don't think
giving it to the government solves the
problem
right i mean libertarians will tell you
why i even have taxes
we need to just get rid of taxes well
there are
a few good reasons for taxes i think are
to protect our roads
and our other roads we got to protect
the road transportation
what's happening here you guys are
supposed to be far right all right
what's going on no you need to you need
to protect people from mercenaries
so standing army is important taxes
helpful in the standing army
yeah i'm a big fan of i i really like
this idea of voucher programs and choice
in in public services like schools maybe
even police departments
so uh we have public school but
everybody pays taxes
the rich will pay obviously more simply
by virtue of having
more money so like ten percent from
someone making ten grand is only a
thousand but ten percent from someone
making a hundred is ten thousand
so that means the poor the rich people
pay more but everybody gets back one
voucher
then they choose the school they wanna
go to and they use the voucher as
a equalized currency for specific
services but they all get the same
voucher exactly okay
which means people from poor
neighborhoods will all of a sudden have
access to the better schools
right and create an incentive for
schools to improve
and and do better oh but then wouldn't
that create a system where schools in
the better neighborhoods would have to
have
admission policies and then they would
get to reject
certain students and then you're going
to get a lot of racist claims
maybe yeah maybe um not i i don't think
you know
it's i'm i'm fairly lukewarm on a lot of
the ideas
because it might it might be really
utopian to be able to be like school
choice is the solution right it's like
you you got to do a lot of testing
maybe there's some pilot programs we can
do and try and figure these things out
maybe there's good evidence suggests we
should at least you know go for it in
certain areas see what happens
i think everybody needs to realize no
matter what action we take there will be
fallout
you know we can we can change bernie
sanders universal healthcare i love the
idea i really do
i just don't know how you do it because
what 20 percent of our economy is based
on the medical infrastructure that
includes insurance companies
administrative that would be wiped out
if we switched the system
plus he's in favor of banning private
insurance which is just not
a good idea at all no one does that like
all the universal healthcare around the
world they don't do this i don't know
why they're americans who want to do
that that makes no sense
so it sounds great this idea that we can
give this service someone
but there's so much in between that
like if we just right now flip snapped
our fingers and said okay it's all
universal healthcare
then i think there's like four million
jobs that get wiped out overnight
and even bernie has talked about this so
how do you do it i'd love to
don't know if you can but i think this a
job those jobs would be recreated
and i think it's not like coal miners to
learn to code
am i allowed to even you know yeah so
yeah so i think it's a different
system from you know i think that the
the jobs are
equivalent in a lot of ways or similar
so that people would then move from the
private
insurance companies and then they would
switch over to
working those many jobs that would be
created by that system it'd be a similar
job so the issue i i have there is just
you know telling clarence who's been
working this job
for you know private tech health for 20
years
you're fired don't worry at some point a
new job will emerge and then you'll
figure it out well that's why
good luck bernie said it would be two
years of pay for them because they
believe it would take two years to get
them retrained and moved into those new
jobs
i just i think that that ignores the
human experience
i think people like their jobs not
everybody somebody they would have the
same job
no i mean like if it's a two-year
transition period where like all of a
sudden their job is gone
well they would go to school they would
be training with the new company a lot
of it right
i think you know uh joe biden said when
we shut down keystone don't worry
there'll be new green jobs
right yeah that didn't happen that's
different though because those jobs are
very different
so i think well no i mean well to an
extent
yeah absolutely but i think in the
private health care
industry there's an overlap but i still
think they're going to be different jobs
you're not going to do the same kind of
paperwork
for the government you would do for a
private corporation and then we're also
telling
you know four million people or whatever
that sorry your jobs are gone
you could tell them like in advance like
hey hey clarence
you if you're working private insurance
your job is going to be gone
within the next 10 years so it's up to
you i can't make you drink but i'm
leading you to the water
i think ultimately though we should go
back and say
i think bernie's plan of abolishing
private health care is nuts we should
absolutely have if we do a universal
system
private as well and that's what every
single other country has
so the way i envision it is there's like
a base level care you get the flu you
break a bone
certain elements that doctors can save
you ready and available
and then you need private supplemental
for the more much more difficult to
treat
ailments that are too expensive and
might overwhelm chronic healthcare
that'd be cool private healthcare for
chronic healthcare things like that but
acute
could be all like government control
exactly so like if you break your arm
you go to the doctor they pat you up
have a nice day um i know
a lot of them on the left don't like
this idea because it means if you get a
extremely rare type of cancer
yeah like what if you or just cancer
private health insurance
what about doing it the way england does
it how do they handle it so they
everybody gets private
i mean everybody gets public insurance
like a medicare for all system
but then if you want extra luxuries like
you want a private room at the hospital
you don't want to share
right you want four days of maternity
rather than two getting kicked out of
the hospital after having a baby
things like that and i think they even
have a system where
there are some fully private hospitals
and doctors
then maybe the private hospitals is the
right way to go it still creates a
challenge though because
uh you're you're what you'll end up with
you'll end up with still extreme
envy and demands don't you think it
would be similar to just school
so right now you've got public school
all of us can put our kids into public
school
but we also have the option to enrolling
them in a perfectly in a in a
fully private school that we have to pay
for because the cost of
treating chronic healthcare can get i
think a lot of it's diet related we have
60
obesity in the united states i think and
that's by people by their choice
to continue to eat crap so i don't want
to fund or saddle people with debt of
lazy
ignorant people that want to live in
ignorance and poison themselves with
food i think it's a little hard
addiction food addiction is one of the
most dangerous addictions
i think i think you had the sugar
industry lie
and manipulated people who didn't
understand and are still doing it
and so to call them lazy i think i think
there's a lot of people are have been
used they've been i mean
right it's like a methodical it is
remember we had ethan's play on the show
yeah and he said he was trying
everything and it was really just like
his entire life trying to figure out how
to get it get it right i don't want to
spend money treating the symptoms of the
problem if we're not going to treat the
problem we have to fix the problem now
you had a doctor but if we had a
universal healthcare system and
everybody had a doctor and you know this
doctor is going to service however many
people
that they've got and that doctor is now
encouraged because of that
system to tell everybody to start eating
right and that the doctor says
vitamin d and eat right what if every
morning at 8 a.m
every american was forced to wake up and
turn their tv on where a giant face told
them to do
squats now no that sounds too much like
1984
yeah exactly i like the way the fire
department's built they don't get paid
per fire
like they don't have an incentive to go
put out fires or i would see firemen
starting their own fires to get paid
more the doctors get paid a lot of money
for selling things
and giving the antibiotics companies
want to force the hey we'll pay you to
sell our products certain drugs if we
could remove that stuff from the
industry and they were actually
we don't want patients we want you to be
healthy if that was their ethos
then i could see a chronic health care
right the only way that could be
incentivized is through the government
vouchers oh i don't know about that you
can just i think we can enlighten people
as private citizens too
but they're not gonna make money unless
the government gets involved and says we
incentivize you to have a healthy
population of people without the
healthier they are we give you bonuses
what if there was some similar type of
voucher system i don't know how that
would work with hospitals but the
general idea is
everybody gets equal access to certain
services but there's still a kind of
market exchange
so private hospital this might be
interesting to you oh sorry let me push
the right button here but i actually
worked for a hospital
not the right button oh my gosh there we
go okay that's not the right button
either the buttons
push all the buttons there we go i've
never done that before i was gonna say
um i used to work at a hospital
literally
in a hospital and one of the things they
did was they would incentivize you
to uh eat right and to weigh the right
amount and to have the right cholesterol
level
um and they would give you a reduction
in your health insurance costs they
covered everything
but if you were high they would help you
figure out how to fix it they would help
you eat right and they would help you
figure out if you actually needed
medicine and that was very useful for
the people who work there this big
company i think we should start our own
country what do you guys think i think
we're solving all the world's problems
right here we do have a good one do you
like ron paul
i do like ron paul ron paul has this
quote where he said something like
there's nothing stopping anyone from
starting a socialist community or city
or town
it's just that socialists want to take
from you and to step back a little bit
i saw that and i'm like i understand
he's going to talk about the socialists
and say they're trying to take yourself
okay fine
but there's a good point in that we
could literally just buy
you know 100 acres and then be like okay
communism here we go we could build a
floating island
so it is an it is an interesting point
from ron paul
that they do just want to keep saying we
get your stuff
but like how about you you go and make
your own commune and there are people
who did
it's about 100 people it is a farm
community
and you apply to join and if they
approve you you work
and you bask in all of the glory
everyone's friends and then people
rotate in and out
and it works they started their own
system which is very it's communism
and it works because it's a small group
of people who have built their own
and it's democratic right and they're
within the confines of a well-protected
country so i often say that i'm not
personally a right libertarian
but i would prefer if we had to create a
government
out of anything it would be more right
libertarian because it means i can start
my left libertarian society
on my own and be left alone because no
one's going to mess with me well because
it would be democratic
yeah right whereas you would also be
able to start a community that was
purely something
opposite of that i saw these bitcoin
millionaires or billionaires maybe
building new cities have you seen these
articles
super high tech the high tech was
there's one that's um coming
right in nevada okay um
it's already the plans i'm pretty sure
it's in nevada i'm pretty sure
it's gonna be that that could be a
possibility to like integrate machine
learning and artificial intelligence and
kind of fix a lot of the [ __ ] bitcoin
millionaires have done really wacky
stuff
you see that there was one bitcoin
millionaire who tried manipulating the
match at the gathering market
no so his idea was that if he offered
enough money he could get someone to
make a deck
it's a game those aren't familiar he
could get a professional player
to play in a certain way that was
completely unheard of because he was
like i'll just pay you to do it
and then he thought that by having that
professional play this this
in this tournament using a weird system
it would encourage younger newer players
to do the same thing which would totally
just throw the game into whack
and he dumped like 40 grand into it just
because he could wow
yeah these people human mind people who
got rich overnight and they're just like
i don't know whatever
yeah 40 grand i'm a [ __ ] get those
people together and give them some
purpose because there's a lot of bitcoin
money out there right
they need elon musk to like sit down and
give him a pep talk
a lot of them are smart people who got
rich some of these i i've met a couple
of bitcoin millionaires
and some of them are dumb as a box of
rocks so there was like a really funny
meme in the early days of bitcoin which
bitcoin's at like 58 000
right now by the way and it was like
when bitcoin was very
new and it was going up in value but
only worth a little bit
doesn't mean more someone's like okay
this bitcoin thing's interesting what
can i do with it
and then uh uh i don't know it was
someone saying like
i bought a couple bitcoin because i was
interested it went up and now i have 20
bucks
and then there was this really crazy
punk rock anarchist looking guy who said
that
he was like i'm a billionaire because i
knew i could buy drugs on the internet
with it so i bought a bunch
and it was pointing out how like early
on a lot of people who are buying
bitcoin
were not like investors or like people
running businesses
it was the people who were like oh i
could use this silk road dark webs
exactly and so i know some people who
got rich
and they're not smart they don't get it
all they knew was like
the government it's not government but
it's money and they're like sign me up
and they've had no idea how it works i
think it didn't get taxed until 2019 as
the first year they started taxing it
that is
crazy people made billions of untaxed
billions
individuals billions um i
earlier you said about the the health
care system i don't like that it uh to
think of it
as a for-profit system i would like a
government system that's not-for-profit
right kind of like the fire department
it's not it's not a for-profit system as
far as i know
is how do you get you know you'd have to
get the
the current incentives out like you
mentioned right and then the doctors are
going to be like yeah but now i've got
all the student loan debt and i've got
to be able to that's another big problem
that's another piece of the puzzle lydia
and i talked about this a while ago
when we had a fire out back in philly um
it's the debt so you don't i don't think
doctors need to go to school for 12
years to be able
to show that they know how to do the job
if you can learn the information and
take the test and show
i can do this then you can do it so
the system that is destroying people
with debt unnecessary i think at this
point the knowledge is on youtube for
the most part
the knowledge is on the internet and can
be learned very quickly or at least just
a
a medical school that's inexpensive we
don't even have those
we have very few medical schools we need
more medical schools and the ones that
we have are expensive
so we have to ask ourselves why school
costs so much i'm gonna push the right
button this time
and it is because the government
subsidizes it i firmly believe that if
the government didn't give so much money
to schools
because you're right you will they will
charge what the market will bear
and if the market bears this kind of
government subsidy i don't know
i mean schools are underfunded not
in many areas like the school that i
went to in chicago it's like
no not but you have a college channel
college colleges for profit
right right definitely definitely yeah
yeah yeah yeah it's a racket
if you could do like a two-year medical
program and then take a bunch of tests
and show like
in person like yes i can do the surgery
on the thing i know all the parts
make them doctor but let's get uh to the
to the the important part here
what do you need to college for you want
to be a doctor good point yes okay okay
sure yeah not even not you don't really
need to go to you want to be a doctor
you want to be a lawyer congratulations
or you want to work
in academia like okay if you want to be
a scientist or a researcher
you do that at universities with grants
but you don't even really have to you
can do private research
same with lawyers what do you need
college for you you don't anymore what
you need high school for
well you would you don't necessarily
need college in the institution that
you're thinking of college but you do
need higher education
so you would need education somehow oh
if you're going to be
an engineer right you need to learn how
to be an engineer otherwise
you can do that on your own not i mean
how many people are disciplined enough
to really learn and then
how do you know you're fi that they're
getting quality education information so
you think you need a teacher
is this it goes back apprenticeship i
think you need a teacher well a good
teacher or a good
mentor can really really rocket fuel
your products right
are you familiar with hacker spaces yeah
but what i'm all i'm saying is that
what you're so you don't like the
institution of university fine but you
still have to have higher education
somehow sure but i mean we have the
internet
yeah but you know you've got to filter
the quality of the information the
person's going to get
right i guess through taking the test
but then you're going to get a bunch of
electronic universities
things that are require certification
and tests like
being a doctor you have to have college
there's got to be some regulation to
that because you're literally working on
people
as for engineering you're building
buildings and bridges and roads you have
to have so there's got to be some
regulation on that too
yeah but it's it's the the the filter
there is
government regulation and the
corporations that are doing that work
so if someone hired like when i hire
like a carpenter to build something i
have no idea what their qualifications
are i don't ask for their degree
but you know part of education i gotta
be honest like a lot of the stuff i get
built doesn't come from somebody with a
degree
right yeah but part of the education
experience
is the peer groups and learning from
those peer groups and being able to
bounce things off of and the competition
within those peer groups and those exist
outside of universities
they don't exist as well i don't think
and i think the company you're right i
think they're better you're kind of
paying for a mentorship
and they they call it teachers now and
they stick 30 of you in a room back in
the day it was you and the mentor and
you know lord give you
this is how you do it that was also how
you do people you're doing good
let me i'll tell you about right billion
people we're trying to i had a i had a
friend
who was going to college for music
business right
and i asked her like so
you've been in college for three years
what do you do
she's like well i'm in school and i was
like no no but you're taking music
business right so you like organize
stuff have you like worked with like
record labels
no i'm in school and i was like okay i'm
a high school dropout and i've already
organized some massive shows that made
that brought in tens of thousands of
people
how do i have more experience in music
business than you do and you've been
going for three years
and dumping 30 something thousand
dollars a year into this right some
some jobs don't require it right like
even the industry i got into
radio when i graduated from college i
went into terrestrial radio did fm radio
for years right
i didn't need a college degree to do fm
radio but the
way i even got into fm radio was through
college radio did you do college you did
great
i did college radio right and then i did
an internship at
a terrestrial radio station um through
college
and that's how i got my into the
industry from that point
no one has ever asked me about my
college degree since i've had my career
but at least it got me in there but i
also think that
for other fields in particular is that
the competition
inside of the universities when you are
competing like my last university where
we were graded on a curve
so you're graded against you know you
can't get an a unless you are the best
student in that class it's not about you
just passed the test and got the
information right
you got to show some level of like
genius how does a curve work exactly
well i wanted to bring a point
so there's there's uh somebody i knew a
long time ago and
they had gotten a job with a web dev
firm they
they were like 19 at the time and i was
really surprised i was like wow you got
hired at this web development company
you're only like 19. and he was like
yeah
and he said what happened was fairly
easy to understand all of the college
grads who went to the company
said i have student loans to pay pay
back i absolutely have to make
you know this salary 35 a year whatever
and then the company said
we don't have 35 a year like we don't
make that much money we have like we're
all making you know
table scraps and along comes this 19
year old who's a high school dropout who
has a portfolio of all this web
development
and they're like this is a great
portfolio and what look you know coding
languages do you know when he like
he was like here's my resume how much do
you want he was like how much can you
offer and they were like 27 and remind
you this is 15 years ago
and he was like wow 9 27
that's amazing and they're like you're
hired and he said his boss told him
explicitly like
we would have loved to have hired any
hired any of these college grads but we
just needed someone who knew how to do
it
and the problem was their salary demands
were too high because of their student
loan debt right so that's what i think
we have to correct
i don't think it has to be like oh we
have to just get rid of college because
then i think we
run the risk of reeling ourselves into a
third world country with uneducated
people
you know i think colleges are on
educating people well in some ways i
mean i understand
i had similar for you i was a theater
major and a lot of my college experience
was doing plays
so i would even get credit for doing a
play i'd get three credit hours and that
was like
on the ground training so i came out of
college being a a professional
semi-professional
a lot of people like your friend that
you were mentioning earlier apparently
didn't doing that business
i think it's right i think the whole
thing's a scam depends on the college
depends on the program i think but
here's the thing so my dad was one of
the earliest coders of coders
okay so back in the 80s before anybody
was doing any of that stuff my dad was
like getting a math
they didn't even have computer science
as a degree they didn't have boot camps
for coding or anything like that
nobody was thinking this was going to be
a thing and he
went to college for coding for computer
science
and then was um you know worked for the
power company
doing all of their stuff and that was in
order for those early guys
to get that information they had to go
to college in order to get it
before they like my grandma or the
internet my grandpa created his own
operating system for his tax business i
need to go to school for it
yeah but still like in order to get like
for example boeing runs on the same
now um operating the uh the code that my
dad knew it's like
they're trying to recruit dinosaurs out
of retirement to come out like they're
like oh crap
you know we don't have uh anybody to no
young kids know this code
it's only the older guys that know it we
need these guys to come out of
retirement but
all of those guys learn that same
language i mean you could maybe create
your own and i know even when my dad was
doing it he created his own things here
and there
but to create us something that is
cohesive
across large corporations or large
companies that could be utilized
together
integrated everybody needed to have that
same knowledge and even now they're
struggling because they can't find
people with that knowledge
i'm proficient in the adobe suite and go
to school for it and it's cross company
and cross computer and cross
program you know what a bunch of but
somebody created adobe suite my guess is
they went to college
it was technically it was it was a bunch
of different people who are creating a
bunch of different programs that
eventually got bought out by the adobe
corporation i guess yeah
you know but there's there's also open
source versions where communities just
develop things
by sharing free and open information and
uh
apache that's a good company
for uh uh video editing and stuff uh
ubuntu for operating systems
i'm thinking about like science and a
lot of science you need you don't maybe
you don't need but like um uniform like
you're talking about uniform of
uniformity of information so that they
can like learn the language of science
like all the equations that have led to
the next equation up to the equations of
all so they memorize this this language
basically a language you don't
necessarily need a college but having an
organized place where people can all go
or to learn it all all the same thing so
they can communicate
but i still online hacker spaces no
physical action but you need people from
all around the world to be able to i
mean it could be physical too
i think we need to bring people back to
like apprenticeships and like hang out
having community and learning skills
yeah i mean i do think we need to
change the way higher education is
implemented
and how it's viewed you know change the
the idea that oh it has to be through
university but i still think we need
higher education
age of automation on the way the covid
lockdown causing all this unemployment
maybe it's the time for people to become
mentors
and to offer what they know to the
younger generation yeah
but see and also hey look the pandemic
was a great this is
sort of my point i don't think people
learn as well
unless they're with the group and
they've got the competition they've got
the collaboration they have people to
talk to they have pierce groups
and now what we've seen online is people
are not able to do it as well
but there's nothing saying universities
need to be that
no it could be well well i think but i
don't think you could just get rid i
mean you're wanting to get rid of
universities like some people want to
get rid of private health insurance
i think that universities have become
predatory systems that exploit young
people
they send these 18 year olds into a
system with no idea what their major
should be
many i think around half of people
change their major and then they get set
with massive debt they can never
pay off which is a permanent indentured
servitude which is nothing to benefit
them but that's the system that that's
the issue
right here business higher education the
business i feel like that about the
church the business of the church
bothers me
right the university system at this
point in my opinion is completely
corrupt and broken
and it can't be salvaged well that's how
bernie sanders feels about private
health and sure
how i feel about that but i'm not saying
abolish i'm not saying abolish
the idea of higher education we can have
universities we just got to
kind of purge and refresh them and then
all four
right like everyone shows you you shop
to a university and you hang out
and you you you have fun and you build
things and you explore things
you're just trying to take away the fun
beer pong you know hacker spaces are
pretty no i want way more
we could we could build a hacker space
that'd be we should we actually
sponsored 3d printers lasers
i was a member of hackerspace and i
built a remote control can of green tea
we just got a couple lasers and
i know i got my face burned into oh nice
you may be wondering how in fact did you
create a remote control can of green tea
did you put wheels on it what is that
magic
what i did was i took a couple a piece
of plastic with a couple motors on it
i took the bottom of an arizona can and
i put it slightly off access on one of
the motors
and then taped it on and then on the
back i put a
motor going the uh perpendicular to
create gyroscopic stabilization
what would happen is the off axis
arizonan in the front when it spun
would create a vibration the vibrations
would reduce
the friction between the can and the
table to near zero
and so it would cause the can to float
you've seen these things they have a
little football game where the vibration
makes them move around
you control it by spinning the reverse
gyroscopic stabilizer
which causes it to go straight and when
you release it it spins in circles
i just built that randomly we can never
work with with electronics
we'll help you get your patents filed we
take five percent of the patent for two
years and then release the patent back
to you
i'd rather create a hackerspace where we
just make everything free we need to we
need to help people patent their stuff
though
have more self-awareness on this issue
tim
are you calling me an ace of spades
[Laughter]
i think that for you things are
different because you're obviously
highly intelligent
and that and so that is an unfair
advantage you know you're you're talking
about these crazy things you're creating
and stuff and privilege
right well it's a privilege of
intelligence that others don't have
and you have the privilege of maybe
certain sort of self
you know the ability to just get
something done because you put your mind
to it or something and others need the
encouragement from others and
would you sorry i don't i don't i don't
know yeah
i was interested yeah here i was like
you know giving you compliments about
being a genius and you're trying to stop
me
um you know so that i think that that is
what you have to not everybody
can learn in the same environment that's
your criticism of
university so that's also my defensive
university
if you could go back in time and not
take out the student loans did you do it
um if i could do what go back in time
and not take out student loans
and not take so if i didn't get this
yeah i would i feel like so when i
when i'm telling young people don't go
to school
what i'm really saying is i often say
this if your parents are paying for it
if you're rich
by all means do what you want it's the
student loan system that's created it is
a predatory indentured servitude factory
i would say i would i would take him out
again i couldn't have gone to school
without him what did you go to school
for
theater acting and that's like a
girlfriend it was amazing
and that's popular and that's a degree
that people would say that's a sham
don't even do it and you know i gotta
build my confidence like crazy right
exactly and i got to meet i did music
and philosophy also kind of useless
jazz i'm a jazz drummer oh yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah we should definitely go to super
chats though because we pushed it a
little bit yeah so we'll take the
audience questions
if you haven't already smash that like
button subscribe and go to timcast.com
because we're gonna have a very special
exclusive
i think we're gonna do the ace of spades
the secrets of the universe
i guess you're gonna reveal to the world
my my uh where my intelligence comes
from or something
right yeah praising me just a moment ago
oh now you want more yeah
i'm kidding but but i think that's
really really fascinating it's
like you're a spade what are those
spades
six of spades by the way right you're
the success i'm an eight so you're
saying ian
become a member that'll be up later but
we're going to read your super chats
right now
all right let's see what do we got here
rocky tau says i know someone in the
minneapolis pd who told me that the chas
here has been around since the riot days
but more of a simple no-go zone for
police it's only getting media coverage
now since we're nearing the shavin trial
shoving trials that you say chauvin i
think is the pronunciation or chauvinism
morgan byrne says the fur boss sounds
like a true cat pitilist
he's a top of the org chart so he's got
to do what he says and the evidence says
yeah not true track media only says no
you were children that never grew up it
has never been we all have that
it was a it was about we all have the
equal opportunity for that grow up
children too many spoiled and have never
been poor
i think one of the big problems uh
that we have these days is that there's
a lot of young people who don't
understand hardship
they were born into like the peak
epitome of wealth in this country
and now that things are kind of not
going so well because we're in a golden
age they're like why is my life not
perfect
i don't know i think the opposite a
little bit actually because a lot of
these kids would grow up after the 2008
crash
and suddenly their parents lost their
homes and they were told they couldn't
have things
i guess i mean ford you know that or the
other yeah
i think well i guess what i mean is i
think i agree with you
that's uh our our our the older
generation had everything and it was it
was this you know peak
and they were born at a time like when
people were doing well and things
started to get worse 2008 was a
smack to the bottom and then all of a
sudden millennials entering the job
market were like
what yeah no job market it's not my
fault this happened right you know when
they blame them they get angry
i had first world hardship like my
parents had
middle class but they would get a job
when you were 12. yeah i got a job when
i was 12.
but i had a job when i was uh what i
didn't learn was how to
run a business and that just that really
messed me up if i had learned that but
like you were working in a business that
your family owned that's awesome right i
was just gonna say that's how i learned
as i watched my family have businesses
and i think that generational knowledge
we hear this are talked about a lot on
the left and there is something to that
which it's not just generational wealth
but the generational wealth is actually
generational knowledge
yeah that what you learned from watching
your parents
when they start a business the heart you
know i watched my dad have to
you know we went through a lot of
hardship in order to have him build that
business and we had to make a lot of
sacrifices and i watched it happen in
order for it to grow and i think that
knowledge is really important but you
don't get that except through that kind
of apprenticeship
sort of thing let's read this one we
have a lot of super chats guys so i
really appreciate it but i don't know if
we can read as
many as we normally do we'll try uh
gizmo says when i went to college we
discussed the financial part before i
got classes
did you not know what you were doing why
should i pay your debt you shouldn't
i do not believe in this write a fifty
thousand dollar check at all i think
that's ridiculous
i do think it's insane that there are
people who took out like fifty thousand
dollars in loans and now oh two hundred
thousand dollars
right like what like that's not fair you
shouldn't owe that much money i
understand there's interest
and some people say well you should have
read the contract and i'm like dude an
18 year old
who has some 40 year old predatory loan
officer or whatever be like trust me kid
i'm here looking out for you the
school's got your back you're supposed
to do it
i'm not blaming the kid for being ripped
off by a con artist but i think the
banks should have to pay it
yeah i just want to make bill gates pay
it i just wrote our fannie mae freddie
mac bailout from 2008 is actually 14
trillion over 20 years
wow yeah so why don't they pay it that's
incredible we're still paying
we've only paid like 4 trillion of the
20 of the 16 trillion that we owe these
banks
2008 bailout i'd have to confirm that
but i just read that today it was
jaw-dropping scott blah says student
debt is your own fault
and i have more student that than you
and i'm younger than you there are
arguments for toppling the state
your financial choices aren't one of
them phony anarchists have no
justification but did you understand
what compound interest was did you do
the calculations did they teach you the
calculations of how to calculate
compound interest
then was it really your responsibility
because you could argue it was predatory
i think it's absolutely predatory and i
think it's it's it's absurd to think
we're going to take some kid tell them
they have to do this because that's what
they've been doing they're
screaming in my ears you have to go to
college you have no choice and i was
like nah i am doing it
but they were like here's all the loan
money i take out and i'm like i'm not
gonna pay that back are you nuts
don't worry where to give you the money
i was like wait you're gonna give me
money and i gotta give you more money
you know my favorite thing ever was i
was like 16. i read an article from i
was a clinton era economist
and he said if you go to any investor
and tell them
i will give you a you know you're going
to invest 40 000
into a four-year investment
and after four years you will owe forty
thousand dollars plus interest
they'll laugh in your face that's the
stupidest investment i've ever heard
and now they try and add oh but it's you
know it's the experience in the school
and it's like no no no
if you had forty thousand dollars you
you know what he basically said was
they did this chart where he said if you
are 18 and you go work at mcdonald's
and after you know the average amount of
time where a person sees a promotion to
assistant manager is like x amount of
months
your your average uh hourly wage will go
up to the average number which is this
for mcdonald's
he was like by the time you're 22 and
your your peers are graduating college
they'll have negative 40 000 plus
interest and you will be a manager
making 40
000 a year by the time you're both 28
they will still be paying off their debt
and the interest
and trying to find work experience and
you will now be making you know x amount
of dollars with a savings of you know x
and he basically showed that a person
who doesn't go to college without the
debt
has more net worth for a while they're
younger so the issue for me when i saw
that was like
would i rather be a 24 year old with a
good salary enjoying my youth
or a 24 year old settled with massive
debt struggling to find a job and then
hoping i could pay it off eventually
i'm going to enjoy being young and go
skateboarding i was kind of like what do
i want to do with my life
throw my parents were like you know the
money is not the important thing
i think the question should be when
you're 50 what do you want your life to
be like
dog in the woods cabin made up twigs and
fishing down by the river well it's just
that you know if you don't the math
works out up until you're only a certain
point but then suddenly all the people
in their 40s and 50s
what have i done with my life well they
surpassed those who didn't go to college
and they're the ones now living a good
life with a retirement and you're still
hustling and bustling in a blue-collar
job
spurious uh correlation is that the
right phrase spurious correlation
so uh what i told you not these fancy
words
what ends up happening there's an
assumption that people go to college
make more money and people who don't go
to college make less money
when the reality is people who are
willing to do
the work make more money and so there's
there's a tendency among say high school
dropouts for instance they say if you
drop out of high school you're not going
to make any money
it's like well it's because people jump
out of high school are typically not
doing it for work ethic related reasons
so you're associating high school
dropout with negativity as opposed to
lack of worth work ethic and the
negativity so if you drop out of high
school
there's a bunch of people who jumped out
of high school who are famous
skateboarders athletes musicians
podcast hosts einstein dropped out of
school
high school i think so so the issue is
dropped out early when they see high
school dropout
they assume everybody who did it for the
same reason and thus they'll be broke
some people drop out because they're
actually working harder and they're
being held back by the institution
yeah the school is not going to make you
successful so what happens is you'll
look at somebody who
doesn't go to college and someone who
does and then see an average
where the reality is people who are
willing to say i'm going to do four
years of this work because i hope i can
accomplish something
whereas the average person is not going
to do it is not doing it because they're
driven they're doing it because they're
not driven
so it's a drive factor versus a lack of
drive factor now if you're smart enough
to avoid the system
and find a way to gain experience
outside of that then you will absolutely
make substantially more money and in
fact
college dropout billionaires make three
times as much money as college graduate
billionaires i don't know i'm sorry i'm
sorry i think it's phd
or maybe it's both actually it's been a
long time since i've reached this i
think if we keep
encouraging people to not go to college
i hope you guys all like your stuff from
china
because we're going to need the chinese
engineers we're going to need the
chinese architecture we're going to need
the chinese technology we're going to
need the chinese everything
because we won't have any intelligent
americans
einstein did he said effort when he was
15 this isn't for me it's too slow he
didn't like the way it worked so he left
and
learned it on his own i just think a
country that's willing to invest and
educate
their population is going to beat us but
who's choosing education
what's being taught the school system
right now is predatory it's not
accomplishing right and what are they
teaching well so
raise your hand wait till you're called
on be a good boy don't step out of line
colleges are different they're making me
a soldier basically
we'll read some more we have a very very
important one here blackrock beacon says
roof koreans are a well-regulated
militia change my mind
i will not attempt to jacob howard says
yes you were promised the american dream
but the country has gone further and
further to the left and here we are
is the solution more leftism perhaps
conservatives have a role
in in this life perhaps like when you
think about momentum if it's swinging
far to the left
it's like a swing a swing set you can
push it and make it swing all the way
around
maybe yeah i will i will also just give
a quick shout out too um if you go to
timcast.com and click
shop we have a shirt that says it's a
diamond hands gorilla shirt
it's a gorilla wearing sunglasses
smoking holding lots of cash and wearing
a suit because
i guess there's a meme among the
gamestop people about you know
guerrillas are stronger together or
whatever and
i guess so i decided we had the gorilla
show i was like let's put him in a suit
give him money and like make a you know
thing so
check it out javi jay says i came from
an immigrant family
we were told growing up that the
american dream was to work hard to give
a better life to our children
yeah that's true and somehow people
think it's that like they don't have
kids and they're going to be rich and
swimming in an infinity pool on posting
photos on instagram whether they're your
biological children or not it's to make
it better for the children
we have a lot of super chats we just way
too many super chips my friends
you guys are awesome nick sheamus says
give me ian or give me death sheamus and
give me a guest that knows what she's
talking about when she talks about guns
that's something spicy should go deeper
on guns
troy dingman says one of the biggest
things the founding fathers screwed up
on was not implementing a congressional
dictionary to define what words mean in
the content of the laws
so we would be able to refer back to it
completely agree
in in legal documents it'll say like
very very specific
like this word hereby means this and
they make sure the words are all very
very
specifically defined vs says ca gun
stores have been completely depleted
no ammo guns on back order i bought a
glock in november
wouldn't come in until february guns on
consignment are extremely inflated
people are getting into reloading it's
been it's been this way since the
lockdown started
wow it's true we couldn't get any
weapons during the lockdown
steven a he says historical scholar here
i
definitely trust this uh no offense
stephen i
don't know your credentials you could
100 own a cannon and military-grade
weapons back in the day
i want some linkage to like the facts on
that i want to know
i'm curious frenzy film says tim
felons can lose the right to arms the
u.s constitution says you can lose the
right through due process
all right well there you go i was wrong
about that i suppose they're they're
the 13th amendment needs to be reformed
in my opinion because it allows slavery
in the event that you're convicted of a
crime and i think that's wrong i think
slavery is wrong and you should not be
in any capacity i think our prison
system's supposed to be
rehabilitative not retribution or
punishment
all right let's see powder pz says i'm
running for congress in ca
to uh go to change.org pz for congress
to sign my petition
to get my name on the ballot let's show
the establishment we're in control
all right well i don't know what you're
running what your policy positions are
hopefully they're good ones but either
way people have heard about you thanks
for the super chat
voodoo m says is a harpoon gun a firearm
i don't know is it i don't know maybe
interesting depends on how the the
chemicals used to project the
thing here we go john hutto says basic
firearm safety and training should be
part of
every high school education ian you
could not pull my gun from my holster
even if i didn't try to stop you there
are holsters designed for retention
yeah but does everyone use those
holsters no and that's that and that's a
good point but there also are some very
very simple ones
that don't even have any crazy mechanism
it's just that you have to pull it out a
certain direction so maybe if you had to
have a holstered
gun and a safety holster that could be
something bro if you're if someone if
you're you're responsible for it it's
all someone has like a
gun tucked in their belt like a loaded
pistol with the safety off
and they're on the train and they're
standing there with their hand not like
it's just asking for disaster in my
opinion those people will get arrested
if something happens but
what's what's going to happen what if
they're dead what if the kid gets
shocked or what if the
bullet hits a train and then cause loose
guns
so i like this holster thing yeah a nice
tight holster teach response
maybe you can open well you can open
carry maybe maybe the law should should
not be about that you can't do it it
should be that it should
it should have to be done in a secure
holster fitted properly and
regularly by the government in which
case you have the ability to bear arms
you can't brandish the weapon but it's
in a secure holster only you can pull
from
that way it's not dangling with the
safety off or something like that it's
in a secured holster you could do like
thumb print activation like your cell
phone
in addition to another security feature
big dog born says i've been shooting all
my life got my first 22 at the age of
four
i view firearms as tools no different
than a shovel or an axe
yeah i mean if you swung a pick at
someone's head you'd cause serious
injury to them as well
i guess you know things can be dangerous
people globalist channel says tim
vaccine ready may 1st
i heard that joe biden apparently made
some big announcement earlier so that's
it the modern one
uh no i think it was johnson johnson he
did like
and something doses maybe 100 million
doses of johnson and johnson or
something
hmm there you go i think that's what
they were saying more than enough i
guess
who owns that company johnson that one
is actually going to do a non-pro
they're
doing that the vaccine non-profit oh
cool interesting
tree of liberty says in 2005 we shot
skeet on the football field in high
school
also my published philosophy professor
called uh called tom mcdonald an astute
philosopher
then commented he was doing very
valuable philosophical work wow that's
really amazing i say that about rap
people think i'm crazy
john society says spoiled rich white
westerners are angrier over the alberta
wisconsin pipeline than they are that
the tur
then they are at the turkey cutter
pipeline as if bombs raining down in the
middle
middle easterners isn't a problem for
them yeah
let's see nicholas cervini says that he
was suicidal his whole life
i thought i would lose my firearms i'd
never had found the help i desperately
needed
just got a little little news on johnson
and johnson the majority shareholder
older
shareholders uh two of the top three are
the vanguard group and blackrock
two of the largest investment firms in
the world along with state street they
basically
own eight percent of every apple
microsoft visor johnson and john you
look down the list crazy powerful
companies roberto flores says tim taking
a stand on 2a
nice oh yeah yeah i'm doing it that's
certainly
the case and it's not so much that i
like the idea of everybody having guns
i just don't think it's an authoritarian
position to try and supersede the
constitution without proper amendment
so then amend it you know nos says that
they've been
suicidal in the past and they went for
treatment for it they did the equivalent
of paying their debt to society
treatment centers are abusive by the way
but now they say they're mentally
healthy
they want a gun and they can't because
of california interesting
curious curious mishap says tim is 200
right on the suicide angle taking away
the gun doesn't do much of anything
butter knives don't work
wow they say they tried and battled
severe depression their entire life
banning never works prohibition anyone i
knew someone that took a bunch of pills
to die
but then they didn't it didn't kill them
and they were glad it didn't kill them
right but i think a shotgun probably
would have got the job done and maybe
they would have regretted it right
kim they're they're they're enjoying
that you're from california and pointing
out the problems of california
will you teach me says i love to see
californians complain but i don't think
it's fair because i think you're a smart
and reasonable person so pointing out
the problems of what's going on and
being critical of it is exactly what we
need from california
lockdie says you can make an ar-15 with
a drill press from amazon the
instructions exist online and has been
for a very long time
yeah all right where are we at
jesse says you saved my business tim due
to me listening to your pending
economy shutdown i was stocked up on
supplies to prepare for it thank you
kim iverson has changed my mind on many
topics please have her on again as one
uh one tim irl is not enough
time for the open dialogue with her very
cool very nice thank you
yeah people were saying that you were
the queen in the chat earlier oh really
because i'm getting hate mail in my
box you know
people need to i just it's like be
polite you know what i mean like
be nice if i think if people disagree
with what you're saying
obviously i think a lot of people who
watch me agree with what i say that's
why they watch the show
but i think if they disagree with a
guest or you the answer is like hey kim
i thought you were great thanks for
coming on tim's show and being willing
to have an open dialogue i'd like to
discuss with you these ideas
i found out this weird phenomenon where
if if you are saying something that is
complex and it's other people don't
understand it they'll look at you and
say
they're not making any sense they're an
idiot because
they don't understand it and so to not
take as much of that stuff personally
usually
well i mean i at this point can't take
anything personal
but this one person in particular is
getting mad saying that they didn't like
my
this is what i'm confused about because
he says he doesn't like my viewpoint on
second amendment saying that i don't
know anything you know here i am trying
to take everybody's rights away
but i thought i made it really clear
that i was a pro second amendment almost
at one point an extremist on it where i
was like i want to have a nuke if the
government can have a nuke
and so i'm not one who is for taking
away weapons of any kind so it's kind of
a funny
like to get mad yeah and what was it
exactly that made them believe i want to
take
rights away and i'll clarify too if like
i don't want everyone in new york to be
having a gun
i think it would be a lot of chaos
however so long as the constitution
exists you can't just choose to erase it
so
i don't know what to say to somebody
when they're like i have a right to do
it i'm like that's true it's in the
constitution i can read it
so i mean i'm i i personally don't like
it
i am not the king of this country and i
can't snap my fingers and make anybody
do anything
so that's how we make our own country
that we talked about right okay
well i mean we have to be the agent if
you're the ace of spades if we buy a
plot of land and make our own like
tim's ville or whatever everybody needs
to be armed because a well-regulated
militia is required for the survival of
our free state
is it gonna be like hunger games or
something no it's gonna be like you know
if a bear shows up
hunger games we need to protect
ourselves from the bear i guess the us
army shows up
well more hunger games i don't like it
if the us army shows up we smile and
wave and say hi gentlemen how's it going
we shake their hand and then we talk
about it give me your stuff
i mean i belong to us now they're not
going to take our stuff yeah they're
going to be alike just pay your taxes
sovereign nation
all right u.s army not taking a
sovereign nation stuff listen imagine
that here's what we'll do we'll start
the sovereign nation
and then when everyone's like you're
just people living in america pretending
it's a cyber nation
no no we're not paying taxes we're just
paying america for security defense
access roads and so it's just our our
nation
is supplying you know uh a payment a
percentage of our our gdp
like all these other countries are
supposed to be doing for nato you see
okay
but literally it's just us living in a
field and paying taxes we'll build like
the united
the united arab emirates of the united
states like a small community of super
high tech
development although we shouldn't have
to pay property tax i'm totally
we got to be a religion right i'm
completely against a religion i think it
should be totally banned
hubbard did it so let's be a religion
then you have to be for church
i like church all right let's see ryan
einsteiner says the mail room job
wouldn't get a pay raise it would become
a sub
40 hour per week part-time job come on
guys isn't hard to see take your heads
out of the clouds
but why would a uh a sub 40 hour a
dollar a week not get a pay raise
right so because it would still be tied
to no matter how many hours they were
our hourly wages would go up
clef the misfit says progressives
talking about raising the minimum wage
are looking at the problem backwards why
is the cost of living shot far past
wages
it's federal reserve inflation abolish
the fed costs will drop
yeah i think like everyone's just like
yes yeah i think there's something to
that
yeah it's basically that so long as they
can keep printing money in the way they
do
they can extract value from us spend it
on whatever they want
and we just get poorer every single day
and they loan it to us at interest which
is crazy
those promissory notes riley luann says
tim huge problem with even a progressive
tax
when rich get taxed they offset by
increasing price of their product
making us pay the tax true to a certain
extent it's not so
simple to say that because the progres
like there's a limit to what people are
willing to pay for certain products it
may drive inflation for sure for that
reason but i
it's tough i i like the idea of the
progressive tax for the reason stated
but ultimately i think it won't work
because giving the government money
doesn't solve the problem
it actually makes it war worse most
billionaires i don't think have a
product
so they wouldn't even be able to do that
that's not how they're rich
you see you see here here evil black cat
says it's amazing listening to this
while all of you seem to recognize the
core problem is the government having
all the power you keep mentally evading
it while advocating for more government
power
mental uroboros i keep i literally said
i like the idea of oppressive tax but
giving the money
to the government doesn't solve the
problem you also have to define the
government
well the the us government is just a
monopoly it's a representation of the
people
supposed to be yeah yeah like if if 99
of us went and did something the
government
that would be the government doing it i
don't i don't think so no yeah
they're all part of it pretty sure like
you know there are a lot of things the
american people don't like and
oppose but the they're just disorganized
if we were more organized
yeah we just have a government that's
not representative of the people right
now but if it were representative of the
people then it wouldn't be such a
problem of them having power because it
would be the people having power
right zanzibar says statists that
complain about morades are
anti-capitalist
we were supposed to have flying cars by
now and it's those people keeping us
grounded
follow zanzibar underscore daleks and
happy belated birthday tim thank you
very much
anthony hamilton says tim thank you for
being real can you please look into
massachusetts
we are just playing follow the leader
and nothing is wrong it's pathetic
please look into it
it needs exposure okay like the whole
state
i guess something's going on with
lockdowns baron of gray matter says it
is against the law to discuss your
salary with other employees i'm german
you're horribly wrong about this
oh maybe they can't discuss it with one
another but i do know that it's
transparent
i'm not familiar with german wage law
forest mommy
says i have a concierge doctor one
thousand dollars a year all in office
visits
covered one-on-one care tests at cost
it's great 36 with no health issues or
prescriptions
need more of it efficient business
and then people make fun of chess and uh
things like that mld says i didn't go to
college because i didn't think it was
smart to take on that debt
now my taxes should go to pay off debt
for for people who voluntarily took on
that debt that can't pay
and i have to compete with them for my
next job i say
no good sir i say we get rid of the
compounded interest so they have to pay
back what they borrowed
and that's it what if what if the loan
system was
you had to pay back uh only on inflation
so no compounded interest it was
basically just like you
you had to pay back the inflated value i
suppose oh
that's something even better than the
entry the interest as well it probably
won't work either
no that would work you think so so like
if you borrowed 30 grand and then like
each year it just adds like you know one
percent
yeah something it just it increases you
just pay back
30 plus whatever the rate of inflation
was
yeah especially for government-backed
student loans that's exactly how it
should be now private loan maybe they
can get away with something but
superman if he wasn't scared of green
rocks says tim can you wish stacy
herbert happy birthday and give a shout
out to the orange pill youtube channel
you talking about max kaiser is the
reason reason why i got into bitcoin
stacy happy birthday and uh shout out to
stacey and max and the orange pill
podcast if you guys want to learn about
bitcoin
and you want to stop being poor then you
should definitely check out max's uh his
podcast the orangeville podcast
has this really funny meme what it's
like a picture of him laughing and says
have fun
staying poor for like the people who
don't buy bitcoin
and uh i'll just put it this way if you
had been a fan of max kaiser and watched
his show and trusted him
you would be worth hundreds of millions
of dollars right now and i'm not
exaggerating
there was a point where i guess there's
like a story about how max gave alex
jones like 10 000 bitcoin or something
and then alex lost it
because people didn't listen they didn't
believe him and he was right the whole
time
i want to shout out stacy you are
amazing thank you for being max's life
you have made him
organized in a way he never could have
done on his own i love you max you guys
are right i wish
back then when max was yelling about
buying bitcoin i just did it
and i didn't and i didn't and i've known
the guy for a long time and it's like
man if i had a time machine if i could
send a message back in time
listen to the man buy a thousand
bitcoins if you're just talking to
yourself in modern day
maybe you're receiving the message right
now by bitcoin i know and i'm still not
doing it do it don't wait
oh man all right let's see where are we
let's find a good super chat what do we
got
frank says tim you're from chicago you
should know it's not what you know it's
who you know
oh yeah in chicago in many of these blue
places these states
you can get a gun if you've got the
right connections
the connection to gary indiana right no
like if you want to legally own a gun
and walk around chicago
then just if you know the right people
they can get you through that process
so what ends up happening is wealthy
individuals and celebrities
in like these these certain states these
blue states like new jersey like you
know illinois or maryland or california
if you if you have access yeah you can
easily get it they just shuffle your
request to the front of the paperwork
basically so it's
it's like in in some of these states you
need to have a justification for why you
need to be able to bear arms
and it's like i'm rich and they go okay
i'm famous oh absolutely
regular person of course not your
constitutional rights are meaningless
pleb
turtle burger says i don't think should
be able to take out a student loan
amount for more than one year's average
starting pay of that degree
i think that would make people choose
more carefully and bring down tuition
or maybe i don't know people have to get
jobs while they're in school and
they can't take out the loans for the
full cost of tuition or
we need to stop guaranteeing it so that
the price of schools go down
some degrees they don't let you get a
job yeah i try to get a job well i did
have a job while i was in college i
couldn't do
class the job and the theater shows i
had to pick two of the three
same with music you couldn't do it but
law school i don't think they even let
you
get a job while you're in law school
yeah and same i think with medical
school you're not allowed
wolfe fault de leon says kim your mom
loves trump what do you think of him
um well like i mean i think
he's ant you know i'm an
anti-establishment person so
i started off really hating trump i was
i definitely had trump derangement
syndrome
in the beginning like you were cured um
yeah
i was i and i also had you know i was
very establishment i think in my
viewpoints
in the beginning like a lot a while ago
before i really started reading the 90s
no like i would say bef when uh in
2016 even you know i was more
progressive i liked bernie sanders but i
think i just kind of fell into the
establishment narrative and then um but
then the more research i did i was like
oh my gosh the establishment is such a
problem and
and with trump i think i started with
trump derangement syndrome but then
through time
i found myself having to to defend him
over and over again which really upset a
lot of my viewers but it was because the
the left had gone so deranged on him
and then i think as i started to defend
him i almost had sympathy for him
right because i'd be like that they're
just making stuff up or they're
you know and so really i just saw a guy
that
you know i don't i don't hate him and i
don't love him but i did think that he
would have been better than
biden getting in office i was very
anti-biden yeah
i agree i agree david marcella says
please tell ian an armed society is a
polite society
i've heard that before oh wow uh drew
the rn says please bring kim on as staff
see some people really do wow
sorry lydia i'm getting your job oh yes
luke says stop the fed from giving money
to all the banks at zero percent
interest
make banks get their capital from their
account holders pay us interest again
interesting that'd be cool all right
let's do a couple more let's see
where are we at jonathan dugger says
freedom is sloppy
suicide isn't going to stop without guns
freedom is sloppy
it's true it's it is tough stuff uh
we'll do one more lucas jeezy says you
should do a super chat giveaway
what is what is that what does that mean
you give away t-shirts i can be your
first winner oh
okay yeah maybe yeah we have a bunch of
the diamond hands gorilla shirts coming
in
we should make that guy the first winner
too for bringing that up lucas gz
uh how do we contact lucas not sure
he'd have to email us at spin the ufo
gmail.com you're gonna get all kinds of
lucas
every single person but he also adds um
ian for vice president
oh just vice president the voice is
crazy crack well you got to be the
president first no you'd be
it would be trump crossland
all right my friends we are going to
have a crazy spacey conversation
about like tarot or like astrology
and biology the secrets of my uh i want
to learn the secrets of how i'm an ace
of spades and how that
gives me psychic powers yeah so that's
going to be over at timcast.com
and just you know it should be up in
about an hour or so but uh make sure to
follow me on all
on all social media platforms but i keep
doing that also social media platforms
at tim cast my other channels are
youtube.comcast and
youtube.comcastnews this show is live
monday friday at 8pm
so smash that like button subscribe hit
the notification bell
and if you're listening on itunes or
spotify or any other podcast platform
leave us those good five-star reviews
and talk about how awesome we actually
really really does help
you wanna shout out anything else uh kim
you just follow my youtube
please because i'm being super uh
suppressed and they haven't let me gain
a single
subscriber in about a year so i would
like to see if this works
yeah so if a bunch of you will subscribe
then maybe we'll see if i can break
through that algorithm in some way
it's always important that you know
people who want to you know get more
content from kim subscribe to the
channel
and i like make sure you actually go and
watch it you know
that the algorithm is is a is a a nasty
beast
you gotta be careful click the thumbs up
buttons when you pop into the video even
if you only watch it for a short period
always smashing the like button that's
what you need
you need people to smash the like button
for you yeah i think and the
notification bell
yeah i don't know if there's anything
that helps me i mean but yeah go to kim
iverson
youtube you know follow yes subscribe
smash all that smash
smash
[Laughter]
devastate ian hey guys thank you so much
for coming i love you
uh ian crossland you can follow me at
ian crossland.net if you want to check
out all my socials and i have a
merchandise store that's
pretty cool i'll be adding more stuff
there in the future thanks for coming
yeah so i think that kim should be on
the other side of the camera i don't
think you should be over here pushing
buttons if we did bring you on i think
that would be great
i know it's true i love my job i i was
going to say too that a harpoon gun is
not considered firearm
firearms have to have gun powder oh i
suppose apparently according to reddit
which knows everything so ian was right
yeah yeah yeah full auto belt fed now
we're talking harpoon gun harpoon gun
yeah
i don't know for your life
[Laughter]
anyway i'm sour patch lids on twitter
and on mines and i'm real sour patch
lids on instagram and gab so follow me
there
we will be back at timcast.com with an
exclusive
segment talking about this weird secrets
of
uh what it means to be an ace of spades
and uh destiny cards
destiny cards interesting the secrets of
the universe we'll see you all there and
thanks for hanging out bye guys
you